you're a guy who from the outside
looking in positions himself as the
Everyman the non-athlete the ordinary
dude but that's really not entirely
accurate I'm quite proud now to actually
have gone from this unhappy School
portrait photographer 2 Shan Conway an
iron distance Triathlon every day
for5
days people have asked me what do you
think is the reason you do these things
and I sort of don't want to know it's an
unpopular opinion now everyone sort of
says oh it's all about the journey and
I'm like s
[Music]
that I'm extremely proud to introduce
you to our newest brand partner on check
out their lineup of super comfortable
sleek and durable pieces for yourself at
on.com Sean so nice to meet you thank
you for doing this thank you for having
me although it may look a little bit
like my home studio we are in London
recording and you made the trip down
you're wearing your kit so I thought did
you just did you run here did you ride
your bike here I was going to cycle I
was going to cycle yesterday and doing
all day it was 220 mile which normally
for me I would just do on the spur but I
thought right let me could I do it could
I do it and then yesterday I just got a
bit busy and then the the sort of the
terer and me CU I'm two characters in
life I'm a monkey and a terrier and I
got to feed both animals uh the terer me
saying do something do something cuz
it's been weeks now and even though
everyone's telling me to do nothing and
just sit on the sofa and Netflix uh I
can't I just can't so tomorrow it's not
in your na it's not I just I even so I
came down on the train with my mate
Chris and um you know like and he's like
mate stop fidgeting what are you doing
likeing out the window thinking about
why so anyway tomorrow so car fist on
Friday so tomorrow got the day off so I
thought well 60 mile 100K to car fist
could I run it and it's it's quite an
easy train line there's probably a train
station every 10 miles so I'll just bail
if I can't do it so yeah I I just got to
do something that's cool so so 60 mil so
you would leave what at like 4 in the
morning yeah probably 500 a.m. uh it
probably take me 14 hours 15 hours I
think maybe uh as I said I I really
should not do this I'm still nursing the
hip thing but I thought let me crack out
the 105 kit one more time and before it
lands up on a frame in my in my garage
actually um and then
yeah so that's why I'm in this got my
running kit well I'm getting a ride to
carfest so if I'm driving by I'll either
wave or or pull over yeah give be a
banana you can just throw it out the
window are you um that's interesting the
terrier and what is the other animal the
monkey is that sort of an alter ego type
of situation like you you try to channel
that energy and transcend yourself in
the way that the iron cowboy has the
iron Cowboy it's a different personality
or David Goin has Goin like these are
ways to get out of your own mental Loop
and and do extraordinary things by being
somebody else alog together yeah I mean
there's
definitely there's a part of me that now
looks back at everything else I've done
and goes is that like that's not you
like there the impostor syndrome part of
me and the person the little kid who was
never picked at school for sport and you
know I was in the seventh team rugby at
my school I think there was only one
other in the of South Africa that had
seven team so we only had one match a
year and um you know I was terrible at
sport growing up I'm quite short now and
I only grew after school so I was Tiny
at school in South Africa which is very
Macho and you know if you're not good at
rugby or Cricket you're a nobody type
thing um so really my my belief which is
so ingrained in me now that I'm I
shouldn't be able to do these things
it's I think it's still there somewhere
so the person who then goes off and does
100 full IR
even now I'm sitting there going like is
that like was that like that can't be me
like I'm not that guy you know um so the
the monkey Terrier thing is is more I've
I've noticed over the years I've got to
feed both those animals in certain ways
to make me like my for my mental health
mainly just for my well-being and the
monkey is what I am mostly and I love
being a monkey I'm inquisitive I break
things I fix things I have to do things
with my hands whether it's gardening
fixing things I'm into woodwork knife
making yeah you fix all cars too all
cars yeah I've got all cars that I'm
sort of messing around with I've always
got one on the go and then just about to
sell the one I've just finished now and
find another one and um yeah so that's
the the monkey but then the monkey gets
frustrated if if if the terrier doesn't
get fed and every now and then the
terrier just needs to chase something
it's one task simple Chase it and then
what I've worked out is and that can be
little things so it can be you know
fixing these projects or learning
something new or the latest thing I'm
chasing is Yoga I've always poo pooed
yoga but this last week I've got what I
did my first yoga thing on YouTube and I
was like man I am rubbish at this and I
was all of a sudden right I hate being
rubbish at something and I it doesn't
dissuade me from trying to do it more so
now I'm all in for yoga so every morning
I'm up at 5:29 I do half an hour of yoga
before the kids wake up
and it's changed my world
honestly because I've I've done
everything I've got ice bar at home a
SAA tried all the different herbal
things for sleep like um theanine and
magnesium um and there's the human yeah
I've done all of that you know I do the
salt in my glass of water in the morning
um but certainly the getting up at 5:30
and doing half an hour of of of yoga or
Pilates I haven't done Pilates yet but
it's definitely I feel has the biggest
impact in my life but the anyway the
terrier for me to satisfy the terrier
for the longest period afterwards I try
and do these long really long difficult
challenges and I find I'm I'm a better
husband a better father a better mate
I'm more satisfied in life I'm healthier
fitter eat better so yeah once I worked
out those I then stopped feeling guilty
for being a monkey CU you know monkeys
are annoying right you know and and I
was annoying and you know cuz I was
always I remember as a kid my parents
going just stick to something you know
CU I'd have a hobby every 5 minutes and
I started sort of feeling like there was
something wrong with me like for having
all these different interests every five
minutes and and it even extends to you
know when I'm doing one of the cars for
example I'll do half a job and then run
out of screws and then most normal
people go to the shop buy more screws
come back and fix that I'm like no I'm
going to go on a move the wheel now and
then do half the wheel and then you know
so we're doing when we bought our house
we uh it we bought it off a 90-year-old
guy and it just needed some tarting up
but Caroline was so frustrated because
I'd do half the living room and then
half the bedroom and none of it was
finished until all of a sudden it was
all finished and uh that kind of works
for me guess that's so interesting
because the terrier would not allow
something to go uncompleted exactly
right the terrier latches onto something
and doesn't let go but the complimentary
nature of these two Essences of who you
are are very cool and to be able to
identify that understand it and and know
what needs to get fed and how they kind
of interlace with each other is is a
really kind of beautiful model the
monkey being the guy who's tinkering
with the puzzle pieces especially with
these huge projects right there's so
many variables there's so many things to
think about pieces moving all over the
place how do they all fit together uh
that's the problem solving part of your
mind and then the terrier is the
tenaciousness and the single mod
to attack something and complete it all
together yeah absolutely and then the
terrier is is once the terrier is
engaged it's Red Mist blinkers on know
honestly like and and it infuriates
Caroline because every now and then the
terrier Creeps in in normal life for
example you know there'll be something
I'll remember in the veggie plot like
halfway through dinner like oh I've not
done that thing for the for the pumpkins
for Halloween and if I don't water them
now I'll forget and I'll literally get
up halfway through them I'm like I have
to do it now you don't understand like
I'm like the opposite of a
procrastinator it's just if I I can't
not wait it's just I have to do it so
for doing these long challenges I found
it's just for me that destination is all
that matters it's an unpopular opinion
now everyone sort of says oh it's all
about the journey not about the
destination I'm like s that no I I
appreciate your your cander and honesty
around that like no I'm going for the
record I'm going for yeah like we can
drape it in a charity and all but you
know that thing where you get the email
and your friend is going to be running
the 10K or the marathon it's like
they're raising money and it's like okay
that's great and that's important and
there's certainly you know something to
be honored and all of that but let's be
honest about what we're really doing
here right like you want to go run this
thing and accomplish that why are we
embarrassed to say that exactly you know
and and for me
it's I just have to do it I can't not go
for the record I just get No Sa
what's what's behind that though like
part of me thinks when you have to get
up from the dinner table and go fix that
thing there's some like dysfunction
around Control operating there maybe
growing up in all these different places
or feeling like your life was out of
control yeah I went to boarding school
quite Young when I was seven um would
come home on the weekends from 7 till
9:00 then 9 hour proper boarding school
people have asked me what do you think
is the reason you do these things and I
sort of don't want to know like it's
working like I don't want to be fixed
actually like there's obviously maybe
something wrong and maybe there was a
childhood trauma that I'm trying and I'm
trying to every High achiever says this
they feel like if they really delve into
that that they're going to lose their
superpower absolutely you know I speak
it's a lie though you know that right
like that's an illusion you'll actually
be probably more fit to do the things
that that you're trying to do okay well
I'm glad you said that actually cuz it's
it's sort of being at the back of my
mind the whole time like should I find
out you know but what if I find out and
it's a horrible
story which I don't remember and then I
find out and then I'm like oh no I found
this out and you know a now I've got to
deal with that I mean you will you'll
have to Grapple with that you're GNA
have to you know reckon with it but I
think ultimately on the other side of
that there's always greater Freedom
happiness and and and and sort of
Liberation for yourself if there is
something there that's being repressed
out of some defense mechanism there's a
survival uh you know kind of dynamic
operating there but at some point in
your life it will likely surface or
perhaps it's already manifesting in
unhealthy ways that you're unaware of
yeah I never hear about people who
undergo that process and come out the
other side and feel like it wasn't worth
it or they're not better for having done
it yeah understand what you're saying
you're say well I might look into it
actually I might look into
it um
no it's true it's true because there's
certain things in real life I like I
don't sleep well I've never slept well
ever although since I'm doing the yoga
thing you have you have to go out and
and do an Iron Man every day so you
canle I did sleep at the beginning the
first month was horrendous I hot sweats
and my average heart rate in the first
week sleeping heart rate was 89 that was
my average for sleeping time I had a I
wore a whoop for the first week and then
threw it away I was like I don't want to
know my is
1% I know you're starting out at 1%
every single day yeah yeah well you had
to go through I mean James said the same
thing there's that adaptation phase
until your body kind of settles into
what it's doing and understands it um so
let's get into that I mean first of all
like how long has it it's been like two
months now four weeks last Sunday com
only four weeks four and a half weeks
wow so how are you feeling how is the
body doing the first couple coup days
after I felt amazing and I was like damn
it I knew I shouldn't have stopped um
and then and then the third day oh I
just crashed and then but it wasn't a
bad crash I was just like obviously my
body had gone right well we're not doing
this again mhm you can just relax um and
then I thought that was the bottom I
thought it would be a sharp drop off I'm
at the bottom and I'm going to slowly
get better over however long a month two
months 6 months a year but actually I
then got worse the next week and then
the third week was really bad like just
I was sleeping a lot but I had zero I
was like a permanent bunk like walking
up the stairs at home I was like this is
tough even though I went on a few bike
rides and my Figures were okay um The
power was okay and the heart rate was
okay but I just felt awful I just
couldn't and the motivation was there
that's the other good thing that I've
been surprised by been motivated to keep
the fitness but I just had nothing in
the tank no matter food wouldn't do it
sleep didn't do it uh stretching doing
the yoga um and this week that shouldn't
come as a surprise though no I know but
the Terry and the monkey They throwing
thoughts in my head and like you know I
have this amazing
Bas squander it I've done 90 hours I've
done 90 hours a week of Zone one and two
training for three and a half months I'm
like that's got to be worth something I
don't want to lose that like I'm never
going to do that again so yeah I'm yeah
I'm want to keep the fitness so which is
why I'm now going to try and do a run
tomorrow and but I'm good enough at
micro analyzing everything yeah there's
and we can go over this there's 10
pillars of endurance that I and every
day on everything I do that's a
multi-day you got to tick every single
box so it's planning uh experience
Fitness Health Nutrition hydration sleep
muscle management mindset or motivation
and community so if you nail all 10 of
those every single day you're going to
be able to nail multi-day endurance
challenges and and you know it's I did
that every single day doing the
105 um and I sort of want to get back to
a place where I'm now you know if I did
that now surely I'm just going to get
you know get over this fatigue but I
know it doesn't work like that yeah it
doesn't and the past you realize of
course intellectually that uh that you
can't persist in hitting it hard like
that every single day that you have to
give yourself this break and the sense
that I'm getting from you is it's
actually easier for you to get up and do
an Iron Man every day than it is for you
to sit down and be with yourself and and
allow yourself to heal yeah I mean just
thank goodness I have kids and an
amazing wife and that has kept me busy I
think yeah in the old days all the other
things I've done other than the Europe
record where I was with Caroline um I've
been single really and that's then my
yeah I don't know I I struggled a little
bit because I didn't had my mind to
focus on them and yeah there's a part of
me you say well why do you do this I
have I have this sort of picture in my
head of my kids as teenagers trying to
learn the guitar and moaning about
having sore fingers I was like you don't
know pain boys yeah you don't want to be
that guy yeah the 105 is actually the
the third longest thing I've done it's
not even the longest and the other one
so I cyle around the world 150 something
days my length of Britain swim was 135
days and then my longest continuous
Triathlon which is 3,500 mile that was
85 days so I've hovered around this long
stuff for a while um but definitely this
one's been way harder to recover from
but I think you're doing pretty good
yeah all I can do is compare and
contrast your experience with that of
James's and I know that James in the
Wake there's a lot of differences in the
way that you guys kind of approach this
and and how it went for you guys but
James you know famously had a very
difficult time and then in the aftermath
his healing process was very protracted
and it included not just fatigue and
depression but cognitive issues like he
went and had to do like brain exercises
like he couldn't think straight I know
you've said um a few things around
memory but that was like during the Iron
Man's but mentally you seem very clear
you seem present and your energy feels
pretty solid whereas James was really
kind of having a hard time and it took
him a very long time to kind of crawl
out of that hole Yeah so I I've thought
about this a lot because I knew people
would be comparing the two of us and I
think there's a couple of things that I
did different that suited me better one
is well I didn't get injured I didn't
get a severe injury like he did so you
know knowing that he had to do that
marathon with the brace with the poles
fast walk like walking a marathon is way
harder than running it with a good
technique um you know his probably
quartis all levels were really high
because he knew that that was at the end
of the day MH he was I think about 2
hours slower than me each day which
meant he was getting less way less rest
and um and also I I read and I don't
know how much of this is accurate on a
daily basis but he said he was doing 3
hours of physio a day which was just
taking away from sleep and for me of
those 10 Pistons sleep sleep is one of
them and it's almost number one priority
for me like I knew I had to get fast
enough to do a full distance
on in zone one or two for one CU I
couldn't be I needed to be at 110 heart
rate all day and if that made me fast
enough to then still get 8 hours sleep
that was the goal and that was and that
happened at around day 30 something and
that came as a result of experimenting
with Physio and sleep to find that ratio
that would work and I think you're
correct I think James had a massive team
and he had people who were working on
his body and he needed that but it did
eat into his sleep and you discovered
that you were better off if you
prioritized the sleep and then worked in
the physio when you had a little buffer
of time exactly that so the first month
I think I can't remember the exact day I
stopped doing daily physio but it was
around day 30 let's say mhm I was doing
about 20 minutes of physio between the
bike and the run and then I was doing
half an hour physio in the evening but
there's a bit of faf time around each
side of that so I was losing an hour a
day of potential sleep and I was slower
so for example on day two I nearly
missed the 17 hour cut off I did 16
hours 55 I think day three 16 hours 45
uh CU I picked up a knee niggle U on the
bike from day one um completely my own
fault I so the new bike I had built I
chose shorter cranks um and I totally
forgot so when I I'd done my my bike fit
on the old bike which had longer cranks
and I put the short cranks on and just
totally forgot so I just measured messed
up measured from bottom bracket up to
seat post I like well that's millimeter
perfect I'll be good and then forgot I
was like 10 mil off or something crazy
and then in the in the chaos of day one
you just never I just didn't pick it up
right so I was super slow then I was
having the physio so I was only getting
you know six five hours sleep maybe 6
hour sleep and then this it sort of
hovered around you know 7 hours up until
30 and then I I remember once the knee
thing was manageable cuz I was taping it
and wearing the patella bands and then
the ankle the right sort of ankle Shin
that had sort of calmed down a little
bit and uh I thought right I wonder if I
could let's try going for sleep over
physio let's just see cuz I can always
just call him if I need the Physio and
it's not working and I did that and it
was a game changer if you look at all my
splits on my website like as soon as
that happened I was you know I was a a
little bit quicker but B my mood was
better I felt like I could push it a
little bit harder and I could sustain a
faster pace which would then result in
me being able to do you know have more
sleep again and then you you're on the
front of the wound you up on the
compounding that interest exactly
whereas James would have a had the
injury to deal with so the cortisol
levels and the pain and all that stress
uh the and he was a bit slower and then
he was having to do the physio so of
course he came out of that feeling like
completely ruined um because I
knew I knew it was doable without a
major injury you know I've I've done my
Marathon a day for 44 days the longest
time I've done a a marathon a day for
pretty much you know I've done when I
was cycling around the world going for
that record was what 200 miles a day 180
to 200 miles a day every day when I swam
the length of Britain I was do four and
4 and 1/ half hours on 7 hours off 4 and
1/ half hours on 7 hours off with the
tide so and that again was day after day
so at least in my head I was naive naive
enough to go well actually I think this
is doable without getting a serious
injury and and the run really is the one
that will dnf you absolutely right
unless you have some kind of devastating
crash exactly because and that's the
other thing I look at all what will dnf
me getting run over on the bike getting
a serious injury which is most likely
going to happen on the run as in a
repetitive strain injury like a
compression fracture or tendon tear or
things like that um getting really ill
Co or something worse uh and the last
one was you didn't want to think about
but a family member um tragedy type
thing so I had those awkward
conversations with my parents and my
sister cuz I was like where's the line
right what what would what would have to
happen for you to pull the plug where
the terrier would have to heal yeah
think well I did have to pull the plug
didn't I on the previous attempt sure
and yeah I'd love to talk about that
disaster yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
let's just uh we're well into it but and
I'm sure I'll say this in in the
introduction but for clarity purposes uh
Sean completed 105 iron distance
triathlons in 105 consecutive days uh at
the outset the goal was to Eclipse
James's record of doing 101 by doing 102
um and there's so many kind of
interesting um similarities points of
overlap with James's experience but also
many departures right on the one hand
you're a guy who from the outside
looking in sort of positions himself as
the every man the non-athlete guy the
the kind of ordinary dude who's going to
go out and do something extraordinary
but that's really not entirely accurate
we can go into the backstory and how you
got into this stuff I think there's some
super interesting stuff there but
the other perspective is that you
actually had a lot more experience than
James did with these extended multi-day
Adventures that gave you not only a
level of confidence going into such an
audacious goal but also uh you know sort
of a library a copious amount of
experience to rely upon knowing that you
could get through difficulties and how
to kind of navigate the training leading
up to the experience but also the day in
day out kind of grind and and and
determining you know in the monkey part
of you what's important what's not and
how those puzzle pieces fit together
yeah exactly and and and you're right I
sort of I am I was the every man because
I just came I was a school portrait
photographer until I was 30 yeah we're
going to get into all that cuz that's
nutty some crazy stuff yeah so but
you're right you know there's there's
two parts of me as well that go one you
know so you're you're the every man one
how could you be doing
who's this guy not going to break
James's record like this guy he's got a
little punch belly he's got a beard he
lives in the countryside he thinks he's
just going to go out and like beat the
iron Cowboys record exactly and then
part of me is going like have you even
looked to my website like honestly I
can't do this look I didn't know you
know when I first started paying
attention to you I I mean I kind of knew
who you were and I knew you had done
some other stuff but I didn't know the
extent of your resume when it came to
Adventure endurance no exactly and then
so part of me is like honestly guys I
can do it please believe me look this is
this is what I've done you know um and
and and you're right you know I'm quite
proud now to actually have gone from
this unhappy School portrait
photographer to you know someone who's
got quite a long CV of doing multi-day
stuff and and you know if it's under two
if it's under seven days I sort of don't
even count it as an event now I've
probably forgotten about it on my webs
other than the cheese rolling which was
23 seconds or whatever but um yeah and
and and yeah you're right it's it's is
that JX position but I don't want to
stop people thinking I'm the every man
because I am and I've been tested I went
to a human performance lab you know the
one that the brownley brothers go to and
everything and I remember secretly going
there thinking yeah there's something
about me right I got some crazy yeah
they're going to write papers on me
forever and they I did all the tests I
did the same test at Jenson Button does
with all the cognition and the and your
reaction speed all the tests and the
heat lab sweat power V2 like everything
threshold lactate
threshold and it was a couple of weeks
later and I go back and then a different
person who did the test looked at the
papers and there was you know they
printed it all out there's about 20
pages and we sit down he's all excited
he's going through and I could just see
his expression dropping right he's like
he you're actually pretty average and in
fact you've got a disadvantage cuz I
lose 3.4 G of salt per liter of sweat
which is almost twice as much as most
people so I really have salt
deficiencies I have to really work on
that as well in the hydration pie chart
of this so uh yeah no one's writing
papers on me for a while yeah but
actually it makes it more aspirational I
hope so to know that you're not some
kind of physiological outlier yeah yeah
well exactly and I think so too because
you're right I mean you've talked about
out outliers in the past a lot of people
will look at you and if they presume
you're an outlier they think oh well I
can't do that because he's this he's got
lots of money he's a millionaire there
which I'm not or's got biological
Advantage which I don't um and that's
why I put on my website the hiccup bit
cuz I you have a whole section of all
your failures all things I've messed up
I almost failed the first time I do
everything because I actually I have no
I really don't care about failing I
don't I don't feel guilty I don't feel
like I've let people down I'm just like
oh that didn't work I'll try again you
know and that's in just in my nature I
don't know why I've not had to train
myself to do it I guess um maybe that's
your greatest gift maybe yeah outlier is
true like you can't succeed if you're
not pushing the envelope of your
capability which means you're going to
fail yeah that's the only way that you
grow yeah exactly I also have a very
short-term memory it's brilliant you
know like all those miserable days and
all this when it didn't didn't work the
last time I'm like yeah whatever um to
the point of actually there was some
things that I sort of did on the irons
now where I'm like I I worked this out
10 years ago why have I forgotten it you
know like little food hacks like
drinking the cream for example and to
keep the weight on cuz I only lost 3 kgs
over the whole time and I lost that CG a
month um which I was pretty happy I was
expecting to lose more hoping to lose
less started at
70 which I didn't want to put on weight
uh because I didn't want to run heavy I
wanted to run at a at a good weight to
start with um and I thought let me just
nail my nutrition and calories at the
start um so yeah it's sort
of trying to get on top of all of that
um which again comes with the 12 years
of experience and and all the different
things I've
[Music]
done every athlete I know is going to
tell you that having the right gear is
key to Performance if what you're
wearing is poorly crafted it's just
going to put distance between you and
those goals you've set you owe it to
yourself to invest in the best and the
best is on I'm obsessed with the cloud
Ultra great on the trails and I just got
the new nextg Cloud Stratus 3 for the
road I'm loving those but an also has
this incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously dawned
it's like this second to none Second
Skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra te and the ultra shorts which have
this pocket right at the base of the
spine that perfectly anchors your phone
no jiggle I'm just so proud to partner
with an and I love their vision for the
future where their gear is engineered
for
circularity so check out their amazing
lineup of super comfortable sleek and
durable pieces for yourself at
on.com yeah I think that that one could
form the mistaken belief that you just
sort of barrel into these things and
figure it out as you go and what I've
learned and discovered about you is that
there's a much greater uh granular
attention to detail preparation and the
daily schedule than one might imagine
because if you go to your Instagram like
you have that before and after photo
yeah and the before photo it looks like
well you were out of shape and you just
trained your way into this thing yeah um
but that's not the truth and I and I
heard you talk about um the endurance
the endurance science aspect of this in
a very intelligent way which is this
notion that people have mistakenly that
look there's only so much training you
can do so you're going to have to kind
of go into this fresh and and get fit as
you go and I think that was in part some
of James's mindset going into what he
was doing and your point which I agree
with entirely is that's a huge mistake
because then you're creating that
downward spiral right if you're not fit
enough where you can you're not able to
go out and do an Iron Man an iron
distance Triathlon in zone one
and finish in time to get anate enough
of sleep then you're going to dig into
your ability to rec and you're going to
just precipitously decline every day if
you're able to do that zone one and do
it in an adequate time period Then you
can recover and you can get more fit
from that but you've got to be able to
do that every single day without your
heart rate exceeding like 110 yeah
exactly and there aren't very many
people that can do that right so you
have to have the endurance base the
restraint the efficiency the
mitochondrial density all of that going
into it such that you're putting
yourself in a position to succeed from
the gate yeah no absolutely and James
says you got to be it's 100% mental and
100% physical right um and I went in
probably 75% physical I the the so I
started in April I was plagued with
illness all of January I had off cuz I
had three or four different chest
infections had a good couple of weeks in
February then the end of February we
went on holiday and I did a bit of
training on holiday but not not enough
and then beginning of March I did a bit
and then it was taper so I really
dropped because what I should have done
uh is I did three sessions of everything
a week um and bearing in mind I'd failed
last June yeah you started in June and
you only got like what six in seven so
seven so I got well yeah let's talk
about the failure there so on day well
firstly my route was terrible I was
doing an Open Water Swim which forget
the cold because was a bit cold I was
losing 45 minutes in admin because we'
have to get to the gate unlock the gate
drive on this bumpy track through a Ford
through a river you know do the swim and
then halfway through the St I needed the
L I'd have to come out wet suit P to L
cold wet suit back on and it was just it
was a terrible decision uh and actually
I had moved to a pool by day five anyway
so I would have I made that CH that
transition and then the same with the
bike and the run the the bike was too
hilly the Run was too hilly um and then
on day five I was cycling a bit up a
real steep uh gradual gradient and I was
like oh I have some food now cuz I'm
going slow I put my left hand in my
jersey back pocket and I my front wheel
went on a long thin pothole and then I
was holding on the the elbow pad for
your elbows go on the tri bars and then
in that sort of I tried to overcorrect
and I just steered left right into the
bush went over the handlebars hoods bent
completely in was a proper stack uh but
the biggest issue is my left leg stayed
clipped in uh and I got up and I shook
it off and I actually thought my left
knee was was done in and I was like oh
that's a bit but I'll be fine and
actually the rest of the bike was okay
the run I felt it so it was the tendon
that goes from the top of your that your
shin down to the top of your foot the
one that used to lift your foot up and
the Run was like M okay this is dodgy
but let's see so day six I woke up and I
actually felt okay swim was okay bike
was okay run disaster I mean I think I
did an 8
run that day I like oh this is not
looking good I'd already I'd already
gone over the 17 hour cut off which is
an unofficial one by the way the the
it's midnight to midnight that you
actually have but the internet wants it
and I think it's I think 17 hours should
be the goal anyway so I've gone over
that um uh then day seven came and I
nearly missed the midnight cut off I got
in at
11:52 or something and then I just I
knew it was over but are you thinking
well this is kind of what happened to
James cuz he was about six in or so when
he had his was he yeah and he figured it
out so I just have to stay in it or or
uh or I'm you know wimping out in
comparison there was a little bit that
Renning space in your mind sort of the
way I saw it was it was two analogies in
my head is one you know I'm in I'm on
the ship and I've not even left Harbor
and we've got a hole in the ship like do
you cross the Atlantic when you're still
in the harbor or you've just left the
harbor or do you go back and fix the
hole um and so in my head I was like I
know I can do this and not get injured I
know it I just believe it inherently
that I can own this and I felt like I
was doing myself a disservice limping it
and and I because I just knew I could do
it and like thrive on it not Thrive
because you're never going to thrive
because it's miserable um and also I was
just so slow that I probably couldn't
have I'd already gone over the 17 hour
cut off anyway so that was gone it was
definitely it got worse like I I
couldn't walk I was in a brace for a
while but the the main thing is I I have
this I had this oil painting version of
how Iron 102 was going to look and you
know on day five someone cut a hole in
the canvas and I'm like oh let me just
go home get a new canvas and start again
and work out what I did wrong and as I
said I have I really don't care for
failure and I I really wanted to do it
the way I had it pictured in my mind
which was going to be difficult yes it
was going to be a slog getting up at
4:29 every morning um going all day like
all that stuff I was prepared for I I
didn't want to just limp through and
just scrape by because I felt like I was
doing myself a disservice um that said
though had it happened on day like 80 I
probably would have sucked it sucked it
up and just done with it but so early on
I was like you know what it just wasn't
in the car and there was a couple other
issues with with crew I I sort of had
crew Rebellion really early on as well
which I haven't really talked about um
you know Caroline caught one of the crew
guys looking for a job on day four like
on his phone like at home on the laptop
like what are you doing oh I'm looking
for jobs so like they didn't believe in
me you know so yeah that's a problem it
was a problem whereas James has his
really good buddies that those guys were
never going to leave his side absolutely
um I've said many times and I still
believe this to be true that that what
James accomplished with his 50 in 50
states and 50 days and then the 10 10
one I think those are two of the most
extraordinary uh examples of voluntary
human endurance and I feel like they
still to this day have not gotten enough
attention or credit for what he achieved
and then I see you go out and do it and
listen I was you know with James on the
50th day of the 50 and I showed up at
the 100th day I mean I saw the whole
thing and like I was right there when he
started to fall apart like literally
less than I don't know maybe a mile or a
mile and a half from finishing that
100th day and the strain that it had put
on his body and what he was kind of
enduring and I was mesmerized and and
and just really um impressed with how he
completed all of that and then I'm
watching this unfold with you yeah and I
couldn't help but think think this guy's
making it look easy and I'm not saying
that it was easy or that that was your
experience but there was
a a difference in tone in the way that
you were holding all of this like it
seemed not effortless but um there was a
sense of ease around it um whereas with
James and what he was doing there was a
i i the word I would use I guess would
be intensity yeah yeah I think I wonder
if it's a British thing like there's
definitely the keep calm and carryon
attitude in in Britain where we don't
sort of we just you've chosen to do this
mate like crack on what don't moan right
yeah I guess well I'm thinking of Ross
Edgley like always cracking jokes no
matter what banter and there's a there's
a lightness to the whole yeah and then
there's also that this tall poppy
syndrome is quite big in Britain where
if you get a bit above yourself and you
know come come back down to mate and uh
you know all the people that came and
joined me who were just randomers you
know I didn't have have anyone as part
of my crew who who came and paced me on
the bike or joined me on the run I was
just relying on people who showed up
calling on SE every day at the pool and
it all was was quite contained I mean
with James it just became metastasized
and like every day there was more people
until you get to the final day or two
and there's there's thousands of people
there and you're ending up in a High
School stadium and there's like Pomp and
Circumstance and um part of that's
fantastic because it was all these
people who came from all over the place
to celebrate and to also share how much
that had impacted them like I was
running alongside people who were
sharing their story of how they were so
inspired and lost this weight and
started you know like that's an
amazing um aspect of the social media
World in which we live whereas with you
it was just like a rag tag group of a
couple people every single day and it
kind of felt like it stayed in that
consistent Zone was that by Design or
was that just the way that it unfolded
so it sort of unfolded that way but I I
was also very aware that we couldn't
have too many people join me especially
on the bike you had a very narrow Lane
in which you were riding it was super
busy public roads British you know roads
um we had 89 Junctions on the course 75
of which I could have stopped to zero
like so it was a lot of stop start you
know on the days where I was maybe 10
back I think the most ever had excluding
the the 102 day was maybe 20 Riders and
even that was too many cars were getting
annoyed um there was a couple of close
calls with people passing trucks big
trucks when they would take one of the
corners would you know automatically cut
the corner and then you're trying to
look over the hedge to see if anyone's
coming and we were very nervous that if
it got too big something was going to
happen and we had three Crashers and one
of them a guy went under a car in the
wet but luckily the car had stopped in
time uh and the other two were in front
of me just overlapped Wheels you know
people that weren't fit enough to
actually do the the course quickly cuz
we were doing a good Pace you know we
were doing
a six six and a half hours really which
you know unless you've a good Rider I
mean that's that's a decent pace and
some people would take their chance go
yeah I could do that and then they would
just head down not looking where they're
going hit a potle overlap a wheel and
then I'd be behind them and I'd have to
Swerve around two of the crashes and
luckily you know I was unscathed but
there was certainly an element of
nervousness to let it get too big so
actually I think even in the '90s I took
down all the information of how you
could join um and figured that actually
if people wanted to join it means they
would they were super keen and they were
would go and look at my stra they're
sort of passing a test just to get there
and I think at one point didn't you you
rode like a five something and it scared
off a bunch of people joined I remember
this actually this is so I remember
James saying yeah the first 10 days are
going to be horrible but day 10 it's all
going to get better and on day nine a
couple of riders came um Adam and Ben
and we blitzed it and I was hanging on
for dear life and uh yeah we did like a
558 ride time and um I remember going
yeah took me nine days James you know it
took you 10 yes I'm one day up and then
for the next week I was ruined but yeah
I had to sort of say to people like
please come you know come and join me on
the bike because that's not our normal
pace and um in the whole 12,000 Mi
whatever I rode I think I only did
about 200 on my own you know the longest
time I did on my own was day two I did
120k 80 about 80 miles of it on my own
and then someone joined and then had a
few other sections where I did about 30
or 40 miles on my own before someone
would just turn up on their lunch break
and do a stint and that was the benefit
of doing a lapped course so it was sort
of 10 mile down a couple of 30 mile
loops and then 10 Mile backage roughly
uh which meant people could do just the
morning bit before work or one lap or
two laps or come at the end and it sort
of encouraged whereas if I did a long
out and back you sort of committed to
the whole ride really so yeah yeah what
was your communication with James like
while this was unfolding oh was great so
the first attempt he was like oh where
are you I want to come and join you and
it was amazing you know like cuz he
inspired me so that there mhm is what
would James do
wwjd yeah like CU what would he do man
you know like he's super six when you
you know when you had your thing he he
would have kept going well exactly I
didn't have this printed on that
kit um so cu the backstory about me
attempting the 100 is I when he did the
50 I was just blown away I was like whoa
this is amazing I wonder if I could do
100 because it seemed the next step in
my my CV of of triathlon so I'm the only
person still today who have who swam
cycled and run land ENT on GRS which is
the length of Britain I also then had
the record for the world's longest
Triathlon 4,200 miles which is sort of
like a quad DEA continuous but the bike
leg was shorter uh and so this was sort
of the next thing and also of the four
types of World Records you can do which
is world's first furthest or longest
fastest and the most of it's the one I
didn't have a record in yeah you didn't
have a most of I didn't have a most of I
had a record in the others but I didn't
have a most of so in 2018 I thought
actually I'm going to have a crack at
100 and I thought of a route so I was
living in the Lake District I was going
to swim in coniston where I lived uh and
then I worked out a bike leg down to
sort of barow and furnace and Alston and
that um and then you could run up the
quieter side of the lake twice and it
was exactly a marathon and in highight
it was all would have been terrible all
of it but I thought of it anyway and
then I got married and Kids and Co and
so I just parked the idea and then when
um James did the 101 I was like oh yeah
it is doable right let me revisit that
um and then that's when I Revisited it
last year and then obviously it went T
up but yeah yeah yeah but you're doing
it you're making it look easy at least
to an outsider looking in um and you're
creeping up on the record you meet the
record you surpass the record
and you decide to keep going James
sneakily snuck in the 101 and didn't
tell anyone which was great uh which
meant you had to do 102 and then after
that feeling good you're like
well do I keep going yeah yeah so
I part of my process is to go into it
believing wholeheartedly it's a done
deal like if I just turn up I'm going to
do the 102 like that's it and I have to
believe that the terrier yeah and and I
do
things in I put things in place to to
make myself believer so for example I
printed numbers up to 123 so I printed
caps and and race numbers up to 123
because in my head I was manifesting
this concept that not only am I going to
beat it I'm going to go way past it and
it's just part of my process to go well
it's a done deal I just have to turn up
and do it um and so I knew I was always
going to go longer I knew I was always
going to do 103 cuz I wanted to see what
it was like doing it not having to do it
like I just wanted to see would my body
just go whoa what are you doing I'm
giving up and I don't make the cut off
or would I thrive would I be like oh the
pressure's off am I going to enjoy this
uh I had spoken to Caroline a week
before and I was like I feel like I can
go on like I genuinely I really do it's
horrible and it's hard but like I feel
like if I just turn up I could I could
roll this out I really think I could and
just I remember the look in her face
like the words that came out of her
mouth were very supportive but the look
in her face was like don't do this to me
man like I'm solo parenting here like
yeah yeah they told me this was the guy
that I was getting married to yeah
exactly and and we sort of had a
conversation she's like right well if
you need to go more you you're never
going to have another shot of this just
go more so and for context your wife is
self-employed she self-employed and you
have like a four-year-old and like a
under twoyear old twoyear old yeah just
under two so was
hard she was amazing yeah she was
amazing and she was coming running a
marathon every Sunday with me as well
first time she'd run a marathon since
having kids so yeah she's I won the wife
Lottery definitely and uh so then I'm
thinking right well I can carry on but
then there's other things to consider
like I'd be moving Christmas day you
know and like the crew the Riders who
join me everyone's like so focused on
102 and that's what I've told everyone
and if all of a sudden you go oh
actually no that's not the end the end's
like two weeks later every everyone's
like so invested in this day it'd be
like moving Christmas Day and I was like
well I can't do that but I tell you what
I don't want to quit either the Terry
and me doesn't want to be the one that
gives up so I definitely will do 103 and
then I'm going to let the internet
decide 104 so I did 103 and actually it
was such a good day I felt really good
the pressure was off um my times were a
bit slower but I sort of didn't didn't
mind um and then I thought right let the
internet so I went on Instagram and did
a poll and then obviously 71% of the of
Instagram hates me yeah and they said
carry on of course and cuz I thought of
maybe just got getting the internet to
decide but then after it was 71% well
there always going to tell keep going
exactly I sort of didn't really think
about that and I thought right well from
now on I'm just going to flip a coin
because then if the coin says stop it's
not me telling myself to stop it's me
just the coin say stop so that's good so
for to do day 105 I flipped a coin and
the coin said carry on uh and then on
105 I flipped it again and I would have
done 106 but the coin said stop and um
yeah that was emotional actually yeah I
remember flipping that coin was it
harder to not do it that day harder
yeah hard the way I can think about it
is imagine having a job that no one else
in the world has and no one else gets to
have and I have it and it's bleming hard
and it's difficult but it's so rewarding
like I'm getting Goosebumps actually
Goosebumps thinking about it it's so
rewarding and the Community that's being
created around it
is sorry that's got me there
um yeah I just would you give it up yeah
wow yeah I just didn't want to give it
up
MH cuz everyone that came and joined me
like I think that's the thing you know
all these people that took time off work
and
everythingoo just didn't think this
would happen um you know it was so
amazing and uh yeah I just I didn't want
to let go of it yeah so
um and that's why yeah just I knew as
soon as I gived up gave up I just would
be getting you know I wouldn't be doing
something that no one else in the world
is is doing right now or gets to do and
yeah that was um yeah that was uh that
was hard but
also it was time to give up because I
remember Monty my eldest going daddy
daddy is your challenge finished can you
play with me now and oh that just cut to
me you know so um oh excuse me no it's
great I mean I think there's there's two
two competing things here one is this
sense of specialness and this honor of
carrying this mantle forward like you
were very present and aware of the fact
that this is a special set of
circumstances and for whatever reason
you're in this position position you've
been chosen or you chose yourself to to
do this thing and there's there's a
responsibility to show up for that but I
think if I had to guess what provoked
you emotionally is the fact that it was
meaningful for other people ab and that
it cultivated community and in that I I
hear and see somebody who understands
the power of of what these challenges
can
represent in terms of it being about
more than yourself right and that's the
true like vein of energy to tap into
like if you want to keep going right
that's the energy fuel the source that
will always give more and more and more
because it's of benefit to something
that's so much broader than you and your
goal and like the terrier yeah no
absolutely and it took me ages to work
out why these guys were w W up at like
5: in the morning and coming and riding
with me and but then slowly you're right
I heard about each one had their own
little challenge one guy wants to cycle
12,500 miles this year you know Clive
wanted to get white shoes and you only
get to get white shoes if you do 100
miles averaging 20 mph then you can buy
your white cycling shoes and he did that
with me and and and everyone some you
know one guy lost two Stone which is
what was that in 40 you know coming to
cycle with me every day James we called
him cuz he came almost every single day
either on the bike or the Run cuz he he
did shift that allowed it at work and uh
yeah it was just it blew me away that
that camaraderie and we still have a
WhatsApp group now of everyone and one
of the regulars actually did a 24-hour
bike ride on my course just this last
weekend so I went and I did a shift from
1:30 in the morning till 8:00 a.m. um as
he finished that and everyone's got
another one of the guys did 300 miles on
Swift as well so it it was uh yeah it
was really really amazing and and and I
just didn't want to give that up because
I was feeling okay don't get me wrong I
it was tiring getting up every day doing
those 14 hours a day not seeing my kids
coming home and Caroline even though she
was super supportive it's hard solo
parenting you know shout out to all solo
parents there in the world it's really
tough
and um but I knew I could just turn up
and and do it cuz like this is what I'm
good at and I I like being good at it
and I I like the reward from it and the
money coming in for charity was great
and like just everything about this
unique experience that no one else in
the world could ever do I just it was
hard to to let that go
really I'm sure you get asked a lot how
many do you think you could have done
and I did hear you say yeah on another
podcast that you felt like you could do
200 yeah yeah yeah yeah I could have in
on the route I had in this country 200
is
probably probably doable with the
weather I think once you start so I
started in April and that was the
earliest I could start it was snowing
like two weeks before and the weather
was terrible in April it just the wind
was horrible like it was the mud the
conditions you know youve you've going
across loads of farmers tracks with like
mck and cow [__] everywhere why didn't
you just go to like AA or something like
that where the weather's
great
the flattest most temperate climate like
I don't know Phoenix or like you know
Dubai or something no there was thought
of doing it in America so I've cycled as
part of my round the world bike ride I
did Miami up to to Missouri down to
Arkansas Texas up Kansas down
Oklahoma um where did I finish then then
New Mexico Arizona to Phoenix and then
stopped at Phoenix I was I I got run
over in in arkans so I I was a bit delay
on my flights and then I've also done I
did the Route 66 bike race in
2016 um and I love cycling in America
and and I think if you were going to do
longer in America and you also wanted to
play the Tailwind game you could find a
town just had a spiderweb of Roads do
the swim in there do the Tailwind game
run at the end go back each night and I
think that would be sustainable to do
this more and more and and actually
because there's two things that people
will do now someone will possibly do
106 solo with no out Riders um or or
they'll go longer much longer so 200 or
maybe a year because in America you if
you wanted to do a year you'd have to
get very lucky with a lot of things like
injury and illness and and that sort of
thing but you could do two locations so
one in the south in the winter one in
the North in the summer um oh that's
interesting it's doable it's and in fact
a part of me is like damn this this is
the monkey I'm the guy to do it like I'm
definitely the guy to do it but it's
just the wrong time in my life it just
wouldn't be fair um but if no one's done
it like in 10 years time I re revisit it
but um no I think I think you could I
think once you get to a stage and you
know if you look at all the people who
do Deckers and double deckers you know
the real the really good people are
doing 10 hours you know so if you look
at so I've done 105 James done 101
there's a lan guy he's done 60 and he
was doing 10 hours 11 hours and I know
why he stopped at 60 like if you go
online you can see all those data then
there's a french guy who's done 41
there's a bunch of Italians who've done
30 and then all the double decker crowd
um yeah yeah I think that's an
interesting
um thing to explore from a scientific
perspective because it it it sort of
puts to the LIE the idea that the people
who are good at this are just the real
slow Force Gumpy plotters you know the
the
145 uh you know minute mile guys but if
you're really fast and you're incredibly
fit and efficient you're actually in a
better position because you're you're
going to get like hour hours extra every
single day and the compounding interest
of that is abely I remember when you
when you did your five around Hawaii
remember the SEC the before the last one
you said you had 11 hour sleep or
something right you felt amazing we got
a little day off and then I mean I felt
better on that day than I did on the
first day on the other things with the
flights and the we were I mean we didn't
know it was like we were getting I got
like no sleep at all so you it felt like
we were just pulling all nighters and
doing exactly and so that's my point
when you don't have the sleep and you
don't have the recovery you you're
having a rough time as you get if you
say as you faster you get more sleep and
Recovery you're on the front of the wave
um let's say slower people choose a
continuous Decker or double decker
because the cut offs are a bit more
lenient and you can sleep whenever you
want M whereas if you're really slow and
you try a Deca you know You' got to be
at the swim at 6 a.m. you might you you
know you might only get in at 3:00 a.m.
right once you start and then you've
only got three hours sleep and then
eventually you may just not even make
the swim so you're right that you want
to get to a point where you can do a for
me with cuz I had 40 minutes in a car
every day I had 10 minutes to the pool
and 30 minutes back home from the run I
oh there's lots of room for improvement
there yeah yeah except I live in the
Hills so I had to go down to the flat
bits um but if you if you if you lived
right near the pool and you finish your
run near the pool I think 15 hours is
your bare minimum mhm each day day for
me it was 14 hours 14 and a half but
call it 14 so as long as I could do 14
hours in zone one then it was it was
sustainable and I didn't crash on the
bike and and didn't do anything stupid
and I managed all the little niggles so
you know of those 10 10 pillars of
endurance muscle management is one of
them and and I'm very good at that you
know this the smallest thing that's
happening you know I got grain of sand
in between my toes I take my shoe off
straight away immediately oh it'll be
fine abely and I'm really good at that
and and if I feel like a little thing in
my hip I'm like right go back into my
memory has this happened before yes
right what did I do that time right
tennis ball here stretch this do that
tape that if it's not happened before
right physio what's going on and I had a
couple of new ones where I was like
what's going on here so we we did some
stretching in Physio and that sort of
fixed it but I get on it super early I
don't let it get to a point anywhere
near tendonitis anywhere near stress
fracture you know I try and nip it in
the bud um I'm always looking at my
technique in my head like where am I
landing on the Run how's am I stomping
on the pedals on the bike what am I
doing with my shoulders on the bike you
know on the hoods try and Vary between
the hoods the drops and the tri bars but
more important than any of that is
what's going on in between your ears
right and you have some pretty
interesting um mindset techniques and
and
tools as you mention mentioned earlier
James famously says it's 100% mental and
100% physical uh on the mental side of
things this notion of disabusing
yourself of any Plan B I think is really
powerful so talk a little bit about that
so when I go into something a I
mentioned earlier I go in wholeheartedly
believing and I really do believe it's a
done deal I just have to turn up um and
then it puts me in a mindset of like
right well I know I can do it I'm know
I'm going to do it where does that
certainty come from
I've just always been like that to the
point of and that's why I fail like my
first attempt at running the length of
Britain got injured failed my first
attempt at my across Europe cycle record
got injured failed first attempt at this
um got injured as well um and
that's yeah and it's probably because I
have this sort of ignorant side to me I
go in probably a little unprepared you
go in completely half cocked from the
GetGo I mean you're a guy I want to get
into your back let's just take a little
diversion to talk about your backstory a
little bit you are born and spend your
early years in Zimbabwe yeah you then
moved to South Africa your dad is a a
big game conservationist Rhino elephant
conservationist yeah so you grew up as a
little kid with like elephants running
around and stuff yeah yeah yeah I mean
we my mom used to get annoyed because
every day she'd wake up and the Elephant
had drunk all the water out my paddling
pool in the garden that's W for for like
weeks she thought it had she like
where's this blim and hole and they got
up early and there was an elephant so I
mean that's a pretty unique childhood
that connected you with the natural
world in a in a way that that that I
imagine um is probably more meaningful
than even you consciously yeah no um
then South Africa then you end up in the
UK and I get this sense that you're a
bit of a rolling stone you don't really
know what you want to do or who you want
to be but you seem kind of content to
just roll with whatever with you know
less than a dollar in your pocket and
just figure it out as you go no
absolutely I mean even coming to the UK
I remember the reason I came I'd done a
year at photography college and then
they asked me to be an assistant
lecturer for the following year just
helping out in the dark room and various
things helping out that the because only
a one year course and then I finished
that year and all my South African mates
were coming back after their 2-year Visa
ran out going oh Britain was amazing I
loved it we got to travel here here here
and here and I'm at the bottom of going
well that sounds cool I can't do any of
that from here uh I got an Irish
passport it's just like a free train
ticket um let's just go I didn't need a
Visa or anything and I think three weeks
later I landed I pretty much sold
everything I managed to scr around and
get1 uh back in
2002 which wouldn't have lasted long
even back then I'd found out about a job
in a salad making factory in Cambridge
which is the ones when you buy salads in
a bag you know which you shouldn't do
but you know it was that factory where
you cut Lett and put them in the
conveyor Bel and it all gets fixed and
then I started working in a photo lab I
did that for six years cut those days
down as the photography grew and in the
early days the photography was great I
photographed Prince William a lot of the
sports stars had jobs in India and
Morocco I worked on the Harry Potter
films in The Stills Department helping
out the main Stills photographer Mari
close um so it was all going well and
cuz the dream was to use the camera as a
passport to travel the world so I was
going to work for National Geographic it
was the adventure was calling it wasn't
the Art of Photography not that that
wasn't important but the real motivator
was you had this drive and desire to see
the world absolutely and the camera was
going to be that unlocking key for all
that I remember as a kid taking all the
pages out the National Geographic
magazine and putting them all around my
bedroom and and then I got to London and
then the reality of paying rent and
buying food and I ended up living in a
room not much bigger than this with
seven of us there was a bunk bed and I
was on the bottom bunk a double bed in
this corner and then three people on the
floor it was so small the one guy's legs
were out the corridor like it was Tiny
we were just like it was almost
squatting but the landlord knew we were
there and we were paying him rent and he
was like well I can't kick him out to I
charge him like 30 quid a week or
whatever it was and um but I just did it
I lived out of a suitcase for a couple
of years just couch I I moved 12 times
my first year in London you know just
trying get more photography jobs and
then I remember there was a point where
I was going to go down from so I was
working 5 days a week and then just
thought well I might as well work six
days a week earn a bit of extra cash and
then I can buy more kits I was trying to
save up for more
cameras I just got to the point where I
got some new kit and was cutting my days
down I think from yeah back to five and
then my flat in London got broken into
and everything got stolen absolutely
everything and I was like a so went back
to my boss at the photo I was like hey
Simon can I go back to six days a week
please and then it took me another year
of working to buy more kit and you know
so I I was working in that lab for six
years cutting my days down but then on
the side of that you know I was getting
some creative jobs but they really were
terribly paid um but they were creative
but the 22y old of me was like well I
need to earn more of course cuz you I
was chasing the money and I found out
that photographing um School Portraits
at Nursery School level just paid quite
well you you know you sell the pictures
to the parents and they all buy the
pictures and and I did that I did one
school and I was like wow that was quite
a good earner and then I was like well
let's do this and I I had a business
partner James and him and I just were
like right let's go all into this
thinking if we earned enough money from
the schools and we got photographers and
to shoot them and people in the office
we would have more time but actually we
had less time no then you're just
building the business and so then we EV
had an office we had seven staff we had
like four photographers two people doing
Photoshop um and one salesperson getting
us and we were we we did nurseries up in
the Midlands around Birmingham all
around London and the Channel Islands
where James was from and uh yeah got to
the point we're photographing 10,000
kids a year and that was the goal more
just a number like it's 10,000 this year
it needs to be 12,000 next year and it
just was we knew each kid was worth x
amount of money per child photographed
and yeah eventually turn this is a far
cry from the National Geographic well
exactly yeah and then you know there's
the part of that goes and it's just like
just suck it up just deal with it it's
rubbish but you're putting food on the
table mate you know Well Done um get on
with it and then I turned 30 and I was
just miserable so I went to James I said
mate I'm out like I'm out like can you
buy my shares like I walk I walk away
and then he was like yeah sure and going
through looking doing 10 years of
accounts and I'm thinking kaching yeah
you know a little bit here not a lot but
enough to sort me out a year or
something and he said I'll give you a
quid mate that's take it all I was like
so you built this I mean that's a pretty
robust stable big business and you're a
partner with one other guy yeah and you
walk away with a dollar yeah and then I
bought I spent three quid on a frame so
four quid on the frame to frame the
pound so he gave me a jersey pound note
it's the only part of the UK they sled
pound notes um I've got in my office at
home now so I've spent four quid on the
frame for this one pound that I gave so
was minus three from day one but you
know for me it was but to reclaim your
life and it was you know what it was it
was me going right this is my symbolic
gesture of a keeping my friendship
because James and I are best mates he
was best man in my wedding years later
even so it didn't ruin that and I'd
known him for 20 years such a good
friend though he couldn't he could
Equitable I mean is this your guy is he
a good friend I don't know well I mean
part of it he he sort of thought I was
dropping him in it a little bit because
I was mostly the photographer the
creative and he was the business guy and
if I left he would all was like well
what about I don't know how to do this
um so there was a part and we had some
loans that needed repaying and he also
sort of didn't like it either so he was
going to shut the thing down anyway um
but then the other part was me going
like I'm not doing anything purely for
my financial gain ever again like and it
was symbolic like I'll take this pound
and this is it I'm going to moan about
it and talk talk about on podcast
forever um but then so then I had this
this sort of like what am I going to do
I wanted to go traveling
but didn't have any money to go
traveling and also like the traveling
wouldn't have scratched the the terrier
which I hadn't quite worked out this
concept yet but I thought I just needed
to do something and then I thought what
if I break some sort of record that has
an element of travel to it maybe I'll
get a sponsor and they'll pay for it
because that's right this idea of seeing
other people who were traveling the
world on someone else's dime and and and
that being draped with this world record
attempt and you're like well why don't I
go after a world record people get
somebody else to pay for it Ro the
Atlantic climbing Everest they all had
like logos of companies like just like
you do you have a lot of logos on right
now and that because all sport relies on
sponsorship from every level right but
you
nothing you were in no position to ask
anybody for money or or to back you in
any kind of feat I hady given a resume
that had zero experience on it yeah no I
no I got I uh like nothing nothing no
but I got lucky I um I found a company
that supported a charity and I went in
with this sort of idea that well what if
you support my so the thing I thought of
was the round the world record right
riding your bike all the way around the
world was that like a lwh hanging fruit
record in terms of time sort of um it
was still you had to do
aund
67 miles a day so it's still hard but
the current guy who's got the record to
240 miles a day fully supported Mark
Bowmont um so Alan bate had the record
uh and Vin Cox so Vin Cox had the record
but only for a few days because him and
Alan Bay were actually going together
and then Alan bate took his record but
Vin Cox thought of this concept of like
well whoever wants to go for the next
record why don't you all start at the
same time and he made it a race called
the global bike race started on the uh
12th February
201 12 and the idea was start at
Greenwich come back in time for the
Olympics in London it was a awesome idea
so I was like right I'm going to enter
that so I entered that then went to this
company who I knew supported a charity
in Africa I said well if you support me
I'll raise money for you for that
charity and who knows I might raise more
um for the charity and and yeah they
would they just liked it uh they like
the idea the O the CEO loved cycling mhm
and that's how I got funny I was I
couldn't believe I mean it's it was so
rare for just a novice to sort of get a
funding for such a big trip and I I'm
eternally grateful but you did did you
even have a bike no I had a bike cuz I
had cycled L Jonah groz oh right you did
it in like 25 days yeah like a very
casual it was I remember if I did 60k or
something or you know 30 or 40 miles I
was like w I did a big day today so I
had no I had The Adventurous Spirits I
guess but I had no phys iCal ability you
know I remember my first bike ride so
once I'd sort of got an email from the
company saying right I think we're in um
I thought right well I'm going to get my
bike out the shed which a I then
suddenly realized I done lanen joh GRS
on a 62 frame and I'm a 52 so I was I
was like massive massive bike um I I
tried to cycle London to Brighton which
is 60 miles and I got to Crawley got a
puncture and didn't know how to fix it
had to get the train back
home
and um yeah so I was really at a base
but I had the fire I had the fire I was
something for me to Chase and all of a
sudden I knew that if I just put in the
hours I could get to a level because I
looked at Mark Bowmont and Vin Cox and
Ellen bate and James borp and Julian
Sarah all these other people who done
the round the world thing and I'm like
they were just normal people with jobs
and things um none of them were
professional athletes I thought well if
they can do it I'm surely I can and I'm
just going to have a crack and then
train 40 hours a week for six months
yeah how did you ramp up to 40 without
getting injured so 20 of that was on
Saturday I'd get up at 4 4:00 a.m. 5
a.m. cycle through to midnight um and
yeah just slow base base Zone one zone
two cranking out I was
30 yeah 2012 yeah 30 so I I was still
young enough to not pick up all the
niggles I'm picking up
now and yeah just worked really hard and
then eventually got to a point we doing
something like 200 miles daily as long
as not too hilly wasn't
really sort of
Unthinkable so you set about this
attempt to cycle all around the world uh
and Misfortune visits you yeah in the
United States yeah I was uh I was doing
really well i' done so from l so the
rules are you got to do 18,000 miles and
you got to pass two antipodes and
because there's so much ocean in the
southern hemisphere you've got
Wellington and Madrid or a place in
Malaysia and a place in Ecuador and
those are the two I chose uh so I and
you can fly in between bits as long as
you make up the Mars and don't go
backwards on yourself so I went down
flew to Spain so I did a bit in London
but I it really started in Spain went
down into Morocco because I wanted to do
a bit of all the continents except
Antarctica and then flew to Santiago did
Santiago to Lima through the atakama
again doing 170 180 miles a day flew to
Miami and did Miami all the way up into
Missouri and then it started getting a
bit cold so I started turning back down
and then when I was in Arkansas yeah
unfortunately someone just ran me over
um they were speeding they admitted
speeding and they were on their phone I
believe and uh I actually don't remember
anything I went to bed the night before
and woke up on the side of the road and
I remember going how's my bike and they
said yeah it's pretty total man I was
like what just lie to me you know tell
me it's okay because without the bike
you can't carry on it was actually one
of the rules you had to do it on the
same bike for some reason
um so the record was off and I was going
to come home were you in the lead in
this adventure are you you're not racing
side by side with people no no the guy
called Mike Cole um rest in peace he
unfortunately got killed sadly got
killed in a in a bike race in Australia
years later and he was one of the best
in the world and it took took the wind
out of my sale for Ultra cycling for a
while actually he was in that race as
well and he would have I would have
beaten the record but he would have
beaten me yeah he was he was amazing
like he was just so inspiring again just
a yorman with a belly and but it was
just a machine on the bike he he won I
don't know if he slurs the tour divide
record but he he won the Tour divide a
couple of times he did he won the trans
con uh across the Trans Am sorry he set
up the Transcontinental race now that's
just been um yeah really amaz so he
probably would have beaten me even
though I think we were neck and neck his
route was slightly quicker cuz he went
East and I went West um but you get hit
by this car yeah and it's not a small
thing like you fracture your back like
you're in bad shape yeah it was uh you
know I would say to the guy who ran me
over like it wasn't his fault like I was
on a road you should never cycle on but
I'm just following a line on a map you
know he's he he's a baker I believe he's
done this road every day of his life
he's probably never seen a cyclist at
5:00 a.m. and then there's this idiot
you know and and it was raining and
there was some traffic lights ahead so I
think my rear red light and the red
light reflection off the water in the
road so yeah no no hard feelings was
just one of those unlucky things but
yeah I just woke up with a compression
fracture on t11 chip tooth
concussion um ligaments like knee and
right foot cuz they stayed clipped in
sorry yeah right cuz that's I must have
swerved at the last minute because I
landed on the grass um and he hit me in
one of your big pickup trucks you know
the ones you you don't get here in
Europe uh went straight up hit the wind
screen my helmet did what a helmet's
meant to do and and compressed and took
took the pressure my rear wheel like it
just was trash the frame was bent um and
it was it was Game Over really for the
record even though I thought I could
carry on the doctors were like nah it's
not happening and it turns out that the
doctor on duty Martin KY was Welsh and
he's like right don't stay in the
hospital come to my house and they the
the carries Martin and Missy are just oh
I owe them everything they just looked
after me you're in Arkansas yeah and you
go to the hospital yeah and it's a
Welshman I know what child yeah so I
mean I owe them everything and they took
me home and they bought me a new bike
they phoned the bike shop here in the UK
and said remember Sean can you send us a
new bike please we'll pay for it yeah
they were amazing so I was of course I
was this is so before they bought me a
bike I was going to come home um and
then I remember going through my kits
and I came across this little Olympic
torch at some kids at a school near the
Olympic Village in Greenwich made me and
the idea was are going to take this
torch around the world back to London
for the Olympics and I'm looking at it
going oh man these kids are going to be
so disappointed um that I don't take
their torch around the worlds and then
all of a sudden the terer had something
to chase again and I was like right I'm
carrying on but then I sort of had this
not for the record not for the
record experience experience get this
tortured back to the kids I had to
convince my parents and I was
like like this is going to be a hard
sell you know like and then I thought
right I've got it so I remember phone
them and say hey Mom and Dad you know
statistically no one gets run over twice
like I've had my turn I'm carrying on
see you
bye which in my head still makes sense
but um it was the only way I could
justify carrying on in my head and
feeling like right well I'm not going to
get run over again and I've got this
torch to get back to the kids so I did
slightly less
mileage uh I think I was 2,000 miles
short of the 18,000 in the end um and a
slightly different route in in Australia
but yeah I got back to the impix
I can't completed that completed that
completed that so this is a very
circuitous uh route that we've taken for
me to arrive at the original point that
I wanted to make which was twofold on
the one hand back to this mindset thing
around no plan B the terrier you latch
on to something it's going to happen no
matter what so much so that you sell
your business for a dollar you talk a
sponsor into underwriting this Advent
Venture uh that you have no experience
in whatsoever and despite being hit by a
car and fracturing your back you still
find a way to complete this thing which
I think is unbelievable but beneath that
is
this minimalist sensibility like a
dollar I'll sleep in a I'll sleep in a
room with seven people um you're you've
designed your life and it seems like
even though you're married and you have
kids now you keep your life lean enough
such that Adventure always remains
within your grasp right like it's all
about having a baseline so that you can
go and do all of these amazing things
like there seems to be a lot of
intentionality behind yeah that
construction no absolutely I tried to
lead as simple a life as possible I
lived on a boat for three years on a
canal um in up near Worcester I bought
an Old World War II gunboat that that
Harland and wolf made and they also made
the Titanic so that was a concern but it
was
it was it's beautiful wooden wooden hell
and lovely Arch and it was used um to
rescue Spitfires in the war and when I
took the front paint work off at sled
the round from the RAF round I had the
engraving with the the the Raf in the
back um of the boat and and the stern I
should say and uh and I love boat life
it was super simple you didn't buy that
bigger Telly cuz you couldn't you didn't
buy another sofa cuz you didn't fancy
the current one because i' had have
built-in one M and um yeah it was just I
didn't have a garage to do my all my my
hobbies and that that's probably the
biggest reason I moved off off the boat
uh and also actually
randomly sort of there's how I met
Caroline was just a whole series of
circumstances that if one of them had
not happened I would never have met the
love of my life and one was getting
injured on Route 66 I then was going
home to the boat and it was really flat
I was like damn it I need Hills in my
life so I literally the next week moved
to the Lake District just for 6 months
to finish writing one of my books and to
do some Hill training then a friend of
mine was going to come and climb scarel
Pike the highest mountain in England uh
and she bailed on me like last minute
which means I had the weekend free so I
went to the Kendall Kendall Mountain
Festival and met my wife and if any of
those hadn't happened I would have never
met met Caroline and then once I'd met
Caroline I sort of knew that moving back
onto the boat was never going to happen
so then I tried to keep but thought I
could maybe get it up to the Lakes but
it was it was 60 foot it was long so I
eventually sold it which was a shame but
yeah going back to your point I do try
and live as simple life as possible
without too much distraction around what
I want to do in life and what you know
gets me going but it is hard when you
have kids and family and
responsibilities and all things there
there's compromises because you have
competing values ex um but you have on
your website in addition to a whole
section with all your failures um you
also have a section on Dreams yeah and
one of the dreams that that you have
publicly announced is to live on a
deserted island basically so you you
have this Forest gum sensibility the
beard Forest never stops running um but
here you are like channeling another Tom
Hanks character like you also want to be
Cast Away like I feel like yeah you have
the terrier and you have the monkey but
you also have Tom Hanks like a Talisman
I actually have a tennis Bowl Cole
Wilson I feel like you need to beat this
guy there's some kind of energy you know
exchange here um but this idea of living
on a on a deserted
island um satisfies that that part in
you that that just wants to be connected
to the Earth and and free or liberated
of the trappings of the material world
which which I think is is operating as
part of this desire for adventure and
exploration right it's like how can I
live in a more natural Primal way where
I'm experiencing the world in the most
tactile way possible yeah no I mean
Caroline and I talk about it all the
time you know our oldest is our oldest
is just starting school in September and
there's we do you know we conflicting
with like should we just take a EUR off
and go and find an island and live on it
or just I could see you on a sailboat
with your family sailing around the
world and raising your children like
wild animals or what's that vgo Morton
movie where he's got him in a school bus
oh yeah that's great film and um until
it's not until it goes nutty but anyway
go ahead well no it's true we've talked
about the boat thing I I just get
terribly seasick um because I I have the
L you have a sailing record I have the
sailing record for L and JN gr as well
but I was sort of the t- boy like my
mate two of my mates full sharp Alex Ali
proper Sailors you know fast boats and
everything and um yeah I was just there
to help out and but yeah we did an 84
hours I think we still have that record
I'm not sure but I was ceasing for 5050
of it you know um yeah it was terrible I
think since swimming Britain I've got
tenus as well and I I I was getting into
paragliding at one point and now I've
had to bin that off because I just get
really bad motion sickness so the boat
thing is just I know that feeling of
being seasick for days and weeks and um
but no you're right I would it's it's
probably going to be the thing that I
regret not having a crack at at one
point and Caroline's the same and but
then we've got a responsibility parents
like is it is it a good idea to take a
kid out of school and make them leave
the life you want to lead you could play
that game all day long like you don't
know you have to live your life
according to your values and raise your
children in the manner in which you feel
is is is in their best interest um but I
think whether or not however that plays
out nonetheless you're this person who
who who has been to many places and
connected uh you didn't just you know
Drive around in a tour bus and fly to
places like you've been boots on the
ground traveling at a very slow speed
through amazing swabs of planet Earth
and I think one of the one of the
Beautiful Things is that you can come
back and tell the rest of us what you
discovered right so of all the places
you've been of all the people that
you've connected with and the things
that you've seen like what are we not
appreciating or understanding or what
what can we learn from from what you've
experienced um that could maybe shift
something in how we perceive our own
lives one thing that I whenever I
travel I'm probably the not a great
person to ask this question to because
I'm mostly heads down not talking to
anyone and living out of service
stations but when I do meet people and
chat to people or or chat to people
afterwards who maybe I cycled across
Russia and they saw me and then you know
messaged me on on Facebook is that we're
all pretty much the same all over the
world we all just want to get up and do
a job and have holidays and all these
sort of things but also I've realized
that how important it is to have some
sort of physical goal in your life like
anywhere in the world I think anyone
should just have something to work
towards that has a physical element to
it I think we're all way better for it
if we do that and I know if I don't have
some physical goal that's difficult I'm
grumpy and and all the people I meet all
the way around the world they're all
exactly the same we're all the same
we're all humans on this planet leaving
yeah we have slightly different
circumstances and and you know some
people live in easier countries than
others of course um but inherently I
think you know we're all pretty much the
same and we should treat each other all
the same and we should all have a
physical goal right empathy empathy and
connection but as for the physical goal
piece articulate why you think that's so
important explain that to the person
who's working two jobs who's never done
anything physical but they life is hard
enough as it is why do they need to
build something like this into their
life because it's you know for me it's
the same as just breathing oxygen like I
think you you have to do it you know you
have to just do because I think you're
also just missing out on life because
there's a whole aspect of life that
you're not
experiencing by not engaging in
something that that has a a challenging
element to it on a physical side you
know like when you changed your diet you
you've untapped this whole new world
right that you just didn't know existed
and I think the same thing
is is there for having a physical CH and
it doesn't have to be going and doing an
Iron Man it can be literally just trying
to do a 5k my my wife's mom has been
doing couch to 5K all year she's still
doing it um and it's great you know
she's just got this thing she's got this
drive now she gets up and yeah it's hard
um but she's getting there slowly mhm I
would also say is don't be in a rush for
it because I think that's also and I am
I definitely
am all the time you know you know have
the goal but you know be prepared to do
the steps to get there and don't get
disheartened when you're not achieving
what you think you would achieve cuz
you're just going to burn out or get
injured or you know if you push it too
hard and do stuff for the fun of it you
know I'm into mushroom foraging so I
I'll go for a run without my or anything
why is that not surprising if I had to
like draw a picture of somebody who's a
mushroom forager probably look a lot
like you yeah and and actually near me
there's pinis like sure pinis are like
the gold of mushroom foraging and I know
we're all there near me so you know
sometimes I'll just do it for the for
the fun of it and I think that's also
important to not not always realize that
there is a a fun element of of exercise
and Sport and challenging yourself I
it's to L those two things and I think
Beyond just the idea
of embracing doing hard things it's the
Cascade effect that occurs when you put
yourself in that position because
whether you succeed or fail in the
pursuit of that goal You're Building
self-esteem you're raising uh the
ceiling on your own sense of personal
capacity and that spills over into every
area and aspect of your life Beyond just
what you're capable of physically yeah
absolutely you know like you're just
pushing that bar higher and higher you
I've got a a 22mon old he tripped on the
pavement the other day burst out crying
thought he was dying you know we don't
cry now and we trip on the pavement
because we know I'm you know I'm not
going to die if I trip pavement so our
bars already higher and I think it's by
putting yourself through those difficult
scenarios and creating a bit of hardship
in the form of physical activity um will
as you say
lead to all other aspects because the
next time something else happens in your
life you go well that wasn't nearly as
bad as running a marathon I can
definitely do this you know so I think
that's definitely an element in that
side of things yeah back to the mindset
stuff so this whole aspect of the
conversation was kicked off by uh
talking about this no plan B idea which
resonates throughout your life like
you're someone who can pick up on a dime
and go do something else without about
like a safety net essentially right and
carrying that into these endurance
Pursuits talk a little bit about in the
context of the 105 how this idea of not
having a plan B um became kind of a
reliable default Mantra
yeah it was interesting actually I a
couple of close flat family members
actually sort of sit me aside and they
go Sean like what happens if you can't
do a full a day will you start doing
halves a day day like uh no what are you
all about they're like well instead of
just quitting if you get injured again
what if you just dropped it down to
doing halves a day and did 102 halves
instead I was like absolutely not like
and then when that gets hard you can go
down to olypic distance pick and then
Sprint and then eventually doing a
5K and then it's just running or
something um so no it was I was sort of
offended I was like it's just never
going to happen I'd rather fail and go
back to the drawing board and start
again again trying to do the fools every
day then reduce my my bar or make my
ambitions lower like I don't get any
satisfaction about doing halves a day
Zero absolutely zero you know I could do
a whole year of halves it would be less
satisfying for me personally it wouldn't
feed the terrier because the terrier
wants the fools right so and on some
level the terrier is sort of like a mad
alcoholic though who's developing a very
high tolerance yeah and needs to be f
even more and more and more and more
this is a concern this is the Hungry
Ghost on your soul well exact cuz at
some
point I the terer will never be
satisfied he'll have achieved and you
you attempting to satisfy it is a is a
is a lost Pursuit no I know I know that
but I'm like diminishing returns that
will slowly drive you mad absolutely and
and I'm ex i' got another 40 Years of
things to fill I don't know keep telling
yourself that you're running
toward something and and start
understanding or appreciating what maybe
you're running away from I'm not
accusing you of anything I I I am
obviously running towards endway from
something I don't know what it is um
yeah I I can't answer it I wish I had an
answer I'm at the moment I'm just
winging it I'm winging winging it and
see what happens I think cuz no plan B
no plan B exactly I'll just at the
moment I'm good at something and I'm
good at being miserable cold wet hungry
and tired and I'm good at doing
multi-day stuff and I'm good at nailing
those 10 pillars of endurance and I'm
going to keep doing that until I can't
anymore and then when that does happen
then I think of another plan a that's
something else and maybe it's being a PE
teacher at school you know I I really
I'm I'm youth sport is high in my agenda
now um since I've had kids I've just
noticed how hard it is to to try and get
facilities especially in North Wales
where I'm from
and uh so now that's my focus I even got
a letter from Prince William oh you did
I did yeah on day 60 something he wrote
we got a letter through the post with
the Kensington Palace stamp on and we're
like what is this and it was like Dear
Mr com am I being kned yeah exactly is
this the OB what's happening so it's
like Deus Conway congratulations on your
102 and then he wrote a lovely paragraph
and uh on the importance of youth sport
and now because he's the the Prince of
Wales of course and then said good luck
with the rest of your challenge and then
just a signature and it doesn't look
like anything so we were like first we
were like who wrote this we're like it
must be the janitor just got a letter
ahead and then we googled his signature
and it come up and his signature is just
Willie it just says Willy and um but
this is what true Venture Foundation
does right they they all all at the
moment it's north ba North Wales based
where where're they have through the
money we raised are going to have a
grant system for clubs youth clubs and
for athletes in individually youth
athletes that they can just apply for so
all the money I raise is in a pot at the
minute and soon we'll they'll be putting
it out and I'm working I'm volunteering
with them basically indefinitely Ryan
lives near me who who set it up and we
go I went to a youth Triathlon event
just this last weekend and did the prize
giving it was the final event of the
year and we just trying to get more kids
cuz in North Wales only
39% of kids do sport outside of school
wow
66,000 fewer kids in Wales alone do
sport outside of school since Co um and
then we hope to expand a uh into the
rest of the UK spit first Wales then the
UK and then also expand the types of
sports we'll support mhm but at the
moment it's it's Triathlon swim cycle
run and and a couple of smaller ones
like there was a club who couldn't put a
youth volleyball earth water polo in
together because they didn't have the
small balls for the for the kids uh
because no
one give you know so isn't uh is Garen
Thomas from Wales
he's from South wal South wal there's a
bit of a divide between North and South
cuz South has Cardiff and you they got
50 M Pool there's no 50 M Pool in North
Wales for example and the all the other
pools are sort of council pools so you
have to there's a slot and and things
like that and yeah so a lot of the North
Wales kids having to drive all the way
down to Cara for a Gala that's pretty
far isn't it it's 4 hours plus hotels
and everything and there was never never
anything up and nor you live pretty
close to rexam right they're pretty
close to Rex so Americans know reom for
one reason and one reason only yeah Ryan
Reynolds so talk to me about the Ryan
Reynolds effect on that town like where
you live that's amazing so I'm I'm
probably half an hour 40 minutes from
rexam but yeah since him and and Rob
bought the bought the football club
bought the football club and they've
invested good money in it and they're
very emotionally invested in absolutely
and it's been amazing for rexam uh and
I've fully I I don't really watch soccer
football um but I have jumped on the Rex
and bandwagon absolutely cuz they're
they're local to me and a lot of the
Riders created like just a Resurgence of
of interest in the football club or kind
of local stuff or are they Interlopers
from the outside no they've they they're
amazing because they they're putting
money into the town and and now the
stadiums are full and they're selling
all tickets and it's good for the
community and they've gone up a league
as well I think they got four more if
they want to get to the Premiership but
that's a long way off but still uh yeah
it's been amazing so anyway because I
cycled down quite close to rexam on my
website I was uh trying to get uh Rob or
or or Ryan to tattoo the rexam football
club on my ass for uh for 25,000 to the
charity they never that sounds like
something they would do though I know
but I don't think mean he's a marketing
genius I thought that would have been
great so anyway that never happened it's
slop so Rob will we'll see we'll see
we'll see if this makes any impact on on
whether we can make that a possibility
um no plan B you're all in you're
committed just like they on the bum
cheek right now already uh the other
interesting mindset Tool uh that I want
to hear a little bit more about is this
counterintuitive notion of refusing to
celebrate small
wins you would think in the pursuit of
goal a larger goal you have these
Stepping Stones along the way and
emotional engagement and and staying
fresh with it um involves allowing
yourself to have those little wins to
celebrate along the way yeah you feel
differently no very
differently for me if I celebrate too
many small wins in my pursuit of the the
full
cake at some point it there could be a
situation where it's going badly mhm but
I go oh well I'm not doing so well but I
got XYZ from it so for example once I
got to 21 I had the British record
um I could have gone yeah I'm the
British record winner yeah brilliant
yeah make it a big fuss out of that then
once I'd got to which I thought was 42
but it turns out it was 61 I would have
got the European record for the most
number of continuous uh sorry day day
byday uh fulls I could have celebrated
that I could have
celebrated um oh there's a couple other
things that sort of I did and then yeah
I don't even remember them because I
didn't celebrate them but the worry is
that let's say done all those little
mini mini micro celebrations let's say
on day 80 something bad happened the
worry for me was oh well I'm already the
British the the European record and the
British record holder oh I'm happy qu oh
yeah well I can be happy with what I've
done um and that was not good for my
head space I needed to be again it's all
or nothing no plan B I'm doing the 102
or and if I don't it's the whole thing's
a failure like I'm not ever going to go
and start doing the talk circuit going
well I'm actually the British record
holder no it'ses sh yeah yeah for me
absolutely yeah a bit the same as like
oh why why you do the most number of
halves CU I think the record for halves
is less than the fools anyway um I
believe I could be wrong on that but um
uh I think it's in there could be you
could create a record for anything yeah
it's like how meaningful are these
records it depends upon you know how how
um incredible the challenge is I suppose
um how does that square with being
leader of a team when you have a crew of
people and you're Reliant upon the
support that you need to accomplish the
goal right like you may feel like it's
not in my best interest to celebrate
these stepping stone goals but I have
all these people and I have to keep them
excited about what we're doing and I
can't expect them to adopt my mindset
and and have them show up fresh and
smiling every single day yeah I think I
failed on that if I if honest I
think I didn't quite cuz I've never
really done anything with crew before so
I had a crew when I swam the length of
Britain and you know we were stuck on a
boat so they sort of couldn't leave uh
and also that really
was sort of something you know doing a
world's first where no one's even
attempted swimming up the West Coast
that was enough to sort of keep them
excited but and and also I had days off
on that one it took 135 days but I had
good 40 days of bad weather where I
couldn't swim yeah so we got to go to
the pub and you know relax and have days
off and things like that so I think that
kept them sort of interested but again I
failed there I think just motivating
them I'm I'm not very good at
compliments receiving or giving I feel
like I'm very selfmotivated and I sort
of half expect other people to be
motivated enough if you've chosen to do
it just be motivated and do it and I
think I and you know apologize to the
crew now I'll openly say that I'm sorry
for not potentially coming across
visually and verbally as appreciative as
I was cuz I was every day I'd wake up i'
be like these guys are amazing like so
because that's the other thing I did
slightly differently to James I think is
I think his crew were doing all day with
him I can't quite work that out cuz saw
pictures of both of them at the end of
each day they would come in and out um
you know I mean they had you know they
had different roles their job on the
bike was to protect James and cuz there
were a lot of people riding especially
at the end and it was very dangerous so
their job was to insulate him and I
think they would they were taking turns
with that similarly on the run but those
guys I mean they were indefatigable like
they could just you know in incredible
athletes super committed to James but I
think James to his credit really
understood leadership and team building
in a way that
maybe to your own admission maybe you
know there's some room for like growing
and learning yeah I'm just not I'm I'm
not very good at like going to someone
and going mate you're amazing you're
doing an awesome job I love you like I'm
just like I'm I'm bad at that and and I
should be better and I apologize to them
because because what I did differently I
guess is I had a morning crew and an
afternoon crew you can't being Cast Away
and Forest gum and also be a CEO yeah
well I should have been you know and I
wish i' now I wish I'd given them more
attention and and shown them more
appreciation um cuz the morning crew
would do the swim and the and the bike
and then come one :00 which is when my
bike ended usually roughly mhm that's
them done for the day they go home they
can do whatever they want had zero to do
with it outside of going doing a bit of
shopping as well and setting up for the
following swim which of course took time
and then the so there was the two
Chris's they did five days on 5 days off
and then Phil did everything and he
would do all of the run and then he
would do the bike maintenance so I had
some bike swapped out so that I I just
had a fresh bike each day uh and
nutrition and things like that and then
again so he would he had his morning
sort of of course he had stuff to do
before he arrived and and the the bike
maintenance and all that um and but
you're
right I if you're doing something like
this your crew will feed off you 100%
And if you're like oh I hate this this
is miserable while we doing it that
energy is going to trans you have to you
have to take responsibility for setting
the tone you've got to be in a good mood
and and tell them that and it's hard
when things are in pain because there's
there is pain every day all day with
with doing a backtack irons you know
your shoulders are sore on the swim and
your back a little bit on the bike it
can be neck or wrists um uh knees a
little bit on the bike for me and then
the run everything hurts you know all
legs and everything so it's hard to then
be like hey guys good going well done I
love you guys thank you so much um and I
definitely failed on that and I think if
I did it again again or someone else is
doing it like you just need to really
show your crew how much you appreciate
them because you know I they were so
good I genuinely didn't have to think
about anything like the food was there I
got I got my nutrition dialed in I
nailed it I would do it different oh cuz
I I and you'll hate me but I had almost
no vegetables on the whole time you're
like eating yeah so
F Meats milks nuts fruits and Grains um
and half of I think I'd get 3,000
calories a day I was doing about 8,000
calories a day 3,000 of that was in the
full fat cream as like insurance
insurance calories just in case which
kept me at a okay weight I went from 60
I went from 70 at the start down to 67
um 68 is a good weight for me the 67 I
felt like was a bit too light I lost a
bit of muscle there and and put my pce
went down a bit and that sort of thing
but um the crew knew everything you know
once we' had it died in I just had to
turn up and everything was ready and
laid out and they were they were
incredible absolutely just the best you
know was there a dark moment of the soul
in this adventure like what was the
hardest piece so it was around day 30 I
wrote a piece about it on social media
where there's a series of things that
happened um so one of them was I got the
total that we for charity and I think it
was less than 1,000 but on day 30 and
I'm like what why is it so low like like
obviously no one cares like obviously
I've I've missed the ball here no one
cares we're never going to raise what we
wanted to raise which was
102,000 and then Caroline was having a
rough time as well you know that just
that particular day the kids were
kicking off and they were ill and they
just were like not wanting to go to bed
and not wanting to eat and just doing
being kids basically and then so you
know I'm coming home and she's having a
rough time I'm like well what why am I
doing this if like we're not raising any
money for charity at this point
Caroline's having a tough time
um you know and you it's hard not to
look at social media and see how many
likes you get and all this because in my
head that would hopefully transcend to
raising money for charity that that
wasn't as as high as we thought by this
point and I thought well have I missed
the ball on like socially you know what
people do now and like does anyone care
about you know just this guy who you
know can just go off and you know he's
he's leading such an easy life he has to
create this hardship for himself just to
feel fulfill
yeah and there's also a sort of point at
which oh another guy's going off and
doing something crazy like there's
always somebody who's going further
longer farther you know and you kind of
begin to yeah have this immune response
to it yeah so and of course it was a
personal challenge that I wanted to test
myself to see if I could do it but at
the expense of a my family and B like
what are you actually wagering here and
what is what is the why yeah exactly
yeah yeah you want to achieve this goal
yes you want to raise money that's not
really the why like what is the deeper
why well I have to feed the terrier it's
like I have to feed the Teran right but
let's go beneath that oh gosh yeah I
have no idea I like what is that drive
all about I don't know maybe it's social
maybe it's trying to like I wasn't very
good at sport at school maybe I was
bullied uh you know I maybe I've just
got this inherent need
for social acceptance you know I was a
bit of a ler and and I thought I was
happy being a loner but actually you
know doing something and beating my
chest cuz all mammals need to beat their
chest right maybe I need that more than
I thought I needed it
um yeah it must be that it must be an
element of me trying to go look at me
I'm good at this stuff man I the best
I'm the only human on the planet to have
ever done XY z um it's got to be there's
got to be a little ego there that's
fueling this fire which I think is fine
I think I'm happy that it's there maybe
you know maybe it's something just
trying to be cool for my kids you know
be a cool dad although I've reliably
being told that that never happens but
yeah it doesn't it doesn't happen I also
think that's [__] that's sort of
like oh I'm raising money it's it's I'm
doing this for my kids I want to show my
kids it's like no it's probably not that
kids don't care no they don't care your
kids are too young first of all and by
the time they're old enough to
appreciate it it'll just be that weird
thing dad did yeah and the W was 500 now
that yeah so I but in that on that day
30 though and you're you're sort of
confronted with that why yeah cuz you
know I wasn't getting maybe the social
recognition I wasn't getting the people
going in their pockets and giving money
to the charity you know Caroline was
having a tough day that day um yeah so
there's probably a lot of those little
things that well it was played on my
mind and then I'm just like what's the
Blooming Point you know what is the
point I'm just it's just SP
all I'm doing is trying to do a few more
full irons than one other guy did you
know
and yeah it hit me that day is it worth
cratering your marriage and threatening
your relationship with your family all
these things and then failing at a
potential other goal which is all part
of the jigs one I know the charity thing
wasn't as you say the be all and end all
cuz I needed to chase the record but
it's certainly something well something
you cared about and also another layer
of accountability exactly yeah it's
dangling all the carrots you know like
what are the carrots you've dangled in
front of yourself to keep you going
forward and and certainly the charity is
one of them and and you know the ego
side is having a cool Pub story and you
know coming on a podcast you know all
these being able to write the book you
know I love I've written seven yeah
you've written a lot of
books there's one we don't talk about so
why is that where
crap well these these 10 rules of
endurance are clearly your next book I
think so so I'm going to weave in the
sort of my experience in IR 105 plus all
the other stuff I've done into this sort
of experience book of of of the 10
pillars I think so um and that's part of
it I love writing and I love all my
books are in the downstairs toilet so
whenever I go for a pee they're there
and they're reminding me and I just love
having them there um it's ego thing as
well I guess um although you do keep
your the copyright to your written word
for like 70 years after you die so I
love the fact that like my great great
grandkids are going to get like two quid
one month from Dad's book sale great
granddad's Book Sales go to the PB books
even exist at that point but back to
this Dark Knight of the soul the
Reckoning with the why trying to figure
out or or find a you know a place to
plant your flag and and continue forward
how did you get to the other side of
that what did you do mentally what did
you rely upon to um to transcend that
setback um I don't think I did anything
like practically I just was like well
okay this is how I feel I feel that this
is potentially a waste of my time and no
one cares but I've committed to doing it
so I'm going to get up tomorrow and do
it and then I got up the next day and I
felt a little bit better and then I got
the next day I got a little bit better
and then within a week we' had a little
bit more money the kids were a bit
better Caroline was having a good time
she came and joined me and ran a
marathon cuz I think it was around then
she started doing a marathon a day with
me uh sorry a marathon a week every
Sunday um and then and a couple more new
riders came cuz around day 30 all of a
sudden more more Riders sort of joining
me on a regular basis um it's sort of a
don't quit before the miracle lesson you
stay in it these things sh and also a
bad day today definitely doesn't mean a
bad day tomorrow that's one thing I've
learned in all the things I've done if
anything a bad today means it's more
likely to be a good day tomorrow I think
and the same as the other way around a
good day today doesn't mean a good day
tomorrow like you've got both ways well
yeah because you can I remember when I
cycle around the world I you know bits
in America where I'd have a massive
Tailwind I'm like this is easy and I'd
take my foot off the gas and I'd just
Coast because I was pushing less power
and the heart rate was down and I was
still floating
along and then i' get to a town and I'd
say oh well I've had a good day you know
I've done 200 miles 2 hours quicker than
normal I'll just rest up I've done a
good day and then the next day I'd only
do 120 miles I'll be like cuz I had a
head I'm like damn it why didn't I
capitalize on that good day and just do
what I normally do just just do the time
and you know on a good day you'll go
further so I've definitely learned that
as well you know a good day today can
mean a bad day tomorrow and vice versa
so
so Shan the Everyman ordinary guy with
the the numbers in the lab that are
super unimpressive we have this person
right but on some level there is a
talent there is a
uniqueness what is that Talent like what
is it that makes you distinct or or or
different or um an outlier if you had to
identify your strength I mean is it
tenacity is it the terrier I think I
think wanting it because I think there's
definitely a
more there's at least three people who
joined me who I think could break my
record you know local local guys there a
guy called Deca Dave who had the British
record for the most number uh for a
double decker and he was doing 11 hours
for and he was 57 years old when he did
it wow um so he had 20 and no one in
Britain had ever done more than
20 he's 64 now so even he admits that
he's he can feel his numbers going down
a little bit so but you know there's
there are people out there who could
physically do it but it's where you want
to do it for one and whether you are you
know I don't know who said it but
someone said be ignor ignorant enough to
start and stubborn enough to finish or
naive enough to start and stubborn
enough to finish and there's definitely
that element of of just wanting it so
much that you're just going to sacrifice
anything to get there but then there's
obviously all the experience that you
need that goes with it and that takes
time and energy
um so
I think I don't think I'm an outlier I
think there are more people out there
than maybe we think who could do these
things MH um they've just chosen not to
or they don't want it enough um or
they're not experienced enough to deal
with all the little niggles that happen
and dealing with the head space and and
that and that comes with time there's no
way so when I did my world's longest
Triathlon
that was the last time I've been at my
fittest so between 2016 and now I've
been the almost the unfittest I've been
because uh did my Europe record in 2018
and that was okay but that was only 25
days and it was cycling only and I lost
all my fitness after that but I still
think even though I was really really
fit after the the the long Triathlon I
still couldn't have done the 105 then
even though I was super fit cuz I didn't
have the experience in all the other
things that go around around with it
so uh I would love for someone to have a
crack at the 105 like I have no business
in holding this record forever
absolutely none what's the Ally 10% 10
10% of me goes oh yeah oh it'll get
it'll get broken but but I like I really
like the fact that you're encouraging it
to be broken and you're holding on to
that very Loosely yeah absolutely like
send me a message I'll help you I'll
tell you how to do it I'll tell you how
to do it and I know you want to set up a
woman for the woman's record what is the
what
so there's someone who's done 25 in 35
days so uh in America um there's someone
in the UK who's done
20 20 continuous not one a day so I
can't I don't know I don't know what the
woman is but Caroline my lovely wife
she's um she's interested yeah which
would be amazing how cool would that be
what husband and wife so I've I've uh
I've taken the horse to water with her
and she's she cuz she's a really good
swimmer she used to swim competitively
as a teenager she can run she was doing
a marathon a week with me and and we met
cycling so she knows how a cycle she
would just need to get a bit quicker on
I think the bike and the Run certainly
the bike I mean I needed to get quicker
on the bike as well but I've got the
course we've got the crew we've got
everyone where I live and it's your turn
to be to be a single dayare I know
absolutely so I think I think if a
female did a month 31 days I think that
would definitely be be a record I think
it's probably 21 but I think 31 would be
a cool number because you've done a
month of them yeah because if you look
at all my data I it definitely doesn't
favor this record doesn't
favor uh a male biologically like the
power was when you with a group of
riders your power is not crazy high the
Run doesn't have to be fast the swim the
Swim's easy but like as you know it's
Triathlon is very skewed away
and even if you're not a great swimmer
it's still a way to recover from the day
before and limber up if Triathlon was
the run first multi-day day after days
would just be a whole different game
because when I woke up in the morning I
was like I can't walk down the stairs I
I cannot do it but I knew once I was in
the pool once I was a couple hundred
meters in get the blood moving get the
blood moving it fixes everything so I
knew the swim was my safe space I loved
it and even though I wasn't super fast I
wasn't slow either I was an okay I was
doing about a I did a 107 swim time as
my fastest and then a
one 20 I think was my slowest but I was
hovering around 120 total time each day
um about 1:15 swim Time 5 minutes
stopping to eat and and that thing easy
whereas and on a good day and a bad day
you're losing 10 minutes whereas on a
good day and a bad day on the bike it
was hour and a half two hours same on
the Run back to this notion of what
distinguishes you um I think yes the the
the desire the wanting it is important I
think there's this tenacity this
determination the terrier Spirit within
you but I also
think um there's something to this
propensity to action that you have like
you are willing to LEAP before you look
oh yeah um and and that's the naive
peace like not being intimidated or
afraid and not being paralyzed by the
unknowns which I think is something that
a lot of people get overly caught up
with so much so that you decide you're
going to swim the length of Great
Britain yeah and you have like no swim
training no you have no idea what you're
getting involved in right like you don't
really have a background in this you're
not trained up you hadn't swam more than
I think I read three miles was your
longest swim pool in a pool before that
yeah yeah so that's idea as and the
world's longest ultimate Triathlon or
whatever you you call it you kind of
went into that without really training
for it or understanding training yeah no
none of that so there's a there's a
bullheadedness piece to that there's a
stupidity piece but there's also an
audacious kind of boldness to it that I
think is the tip of the spear that opens
up these doors and when you compare that
with not being afraid to fail it creates
an equation that allows you to do
amazing things as long as you stick with
it and stay in the game yeah no
absolutely you've you've nailed it on
the head there with the
swim especially that one a I didn't live
anywhere near the ocean so I couldn't do
any sea training I had zero money um I
got sponsored but there was an
accounting error so the money that was
going to pay for it ended up paying for
about half of it and then I crowdfunded
the rest of the swim I only got it like
s days into the swim so I the closest I
had a pool near me but I was so consumed
with all the other aspects of trying to
pull that swim off because that one
really no one believed was possible you
know 900 mil swim up the West Coast I
was putting stuff on yachting forums
saying oh you know i' like to know about
tides and everyone was just hammering me
down like dude whatever like sailing
it's difficult and a small boat like
it's not going to happen waves too big
tides are too strong there killer whales
in Scotland like I got everything so
people were very cautious of trying to
help because they just thought it a
waste of their time um and that took all
my time and I knew that actually so I
could swim I knew how to swim I'd done
have you heard of this the the biggest
Open Water Swimming event in the world I
think is called the midmar mile in South
Africa 15,000 people know about this
it's a mile across a lake 15,000 people
do it every year our school did it so
when I was I think eight no I couldn't I
was about 10 or 11 I swam this mile I've
done it twice they do eight eight um uh
waves of swimmers and one year I did
after I swam Britain I did they call the
the Eight Mile Club where you do all
eight so you swim it they take you on
the boat back you swim it back I swam it
with ker Anne Payne um and Lex Lexi
Kelly she's American um they uh yes so I
knew how to swim but I just was unfit
and my technique was crap so when I did
the cheese rolling in GL you must have
seen it on YouTube where they roll a
cheese down the hill and people chase
the cheese you I don't know about this
it's a 200y old tradition in Britain
where it's called the GL GLA cheese
rolling they and it's vertical they roll
this cheese down you run after it head
over tail whoever gets to the bottom
first wins the cheese anyway I did that
2009 and just fully ruptured my cap Cup
on my left
shoulder so when I swim and I get
fatigued I drop this shoulder and I push
like that and then so I just have a
terrible left hand technique and it
actually played up a little bit on this
because also from when I swam Britain
because of all the waves I I did and
because I didn't want to get neck chafe
you want to get Rhino neck like like
Ross Ross yeah I know it was crazy and I
and then I just again I'm micro managing
everything and I'm very good at that
like I never let it get anywhere near
what he got because I nailed it early I
started I wrapped a buff in Vaseline and
um lelin so I did a Vaseline and lelin
mix in the microwave mixed it all
together rubbed it all over this buff
put it under the wet suit to stop the
little chafe and then it was flushing a
bit and cold but at least I didn't get
chafe but then I eventually got to this
technique where I would just over roll
like to breathe I would just be doing
that rather than doing that and it was
terrible but also with all the big waves
I'm sort of breathing up in the sky and
if you look at all the pictures on this
swim now in the pool I'm like my head's
up I'm over rolling I'm over rotating my
legs are out like this but I knew I
would get fit on that swim and because
it was there was no time element other
than trying to finish before
winter I knew I would make it like I
just I knew I just swam a mile you know
two miles I could do it as long as I did
about 10 miles a day I think in my head
I was like right I'll get into Scotland
before winter uh even though I was
hoping to do more than that but it
landed up being much slower I thought it
was going to take me two and a half
months took me like four and a half or
something yeah 13 yeah right this
propensity to act like you threw
yourself into this thing and figured it
out as you went and as a result you've
accomplished things that you probably
couldn't have imagined for yourself yeah
so I'm trying to I'm trying to like mine
the lesson from that and I think it's
that courage to kind of liberate
yourself from this social
um this imprint uh this impr printed
kind of social expectation or or
attitude that we have around Safety and
Security and like always knowing like
where each step is going to lead you
along the path and and you're just kind
of bouncing around like a ping pingpong
ball like I'm sure there's more
conscious intention behind it
but I see somebody Who's acting on
Instinct and and really driven by this
sense of adventure and is is kind of
just going from one thing to the next
and not spending too much time worrying
about what the larger plan is here like
trying to be really in the moment with
who you who you are yeah no it's true
and I think once I think of something
it's just like well that's what I want
to do now no I'm just going to do it
like I'm not prepared yeah and and that
is like a forest gum thing like I'm okay
I'm going to run now and then like okay
I'm done no exactly and then obviously
where it sort of bites me in the ass a
little bit sometimes is there's there's
weather windows and you know so last
year for last year's attempt I thought
of it in December because I had this
other idea which I can't talk about
which I was going to do which you know
about but that just kept getting delayed
and delayed delayed well I don't want
someone else to do
it right if I someone else like oh I'm
gonna have a crack of that they make my
life I'm sure somebody else has thought
of it maybe knowing what it is well no
one's done it since 1994 so now you're
giving Clues oh exactly but um
I then in December
2021 I decided right I'm going to go for
the
102 and then I looked at the training I
was like right maybe six months it's
cutting it fine but I can't really start
later than July because then I'm running
into October November and weather and
all that sort of thing so that was also
partly the issue with the previous
attempt and also kit like like getting
kit with the supply chain issues getting
a bike was possible um you and James
both like outdoing it in freezing
weather and like what are you guys doing
just relocate this whole thing well he
had more I think he had more variation
on temperature but I just had the rain
you know just the rain just made cycling
on the roads with Pooles you know all
the water just covered up all the Pooles
and you couldn't see them and luckily
you know within a week I knew every
potle by name pretty much so uh that
wasn't too bad but it was slippery and
taking Corners you have to slow down I
was on a rainy day I was easily half an
hour slower just because it was raining
you know cuz your glasses are covered up
with all the muck off the road and
things like that um so yeah what was the
question I'm sure there was
one uh being present with who you are
and not getting caught up in the
security blanket sort of narrative about
around how to live your life like the
guiding princip
around how you're living and how you're
making decisions about where to invest
your time and your energy as opposed to
the 401K or the you know the upwardly
mobile career path yeah you're just like
well here's what I'm doing here's what I
think I'm going to do now and that's
kind of it pretty much I know it's it's
going to is your different oh she's
she's terrified of the
future um no it's
again even sitting here I I can't even
genuinely give you a reasonable sensible
answer because I don't know because it's
just not how my brain works but I think
the the the bandwidth of your life like
the Horizon of your life is obviously
quite large right now you're writing
books you're traveling around you're
giving talks you're speaking you're
doing all these things that would
probably really impress the young
photographer who had dreams of being a
National Geographic fellow right so when
you think back to the aspirations of
that person and reflect upon your life
today yeah what is the message that you
tell that that young person with a
dream just don't be scared to just wink
like have a go you know I and I think
that's what I do I just think of
something that I would potentially
regret not doing you know that's quite
an important thing and I think that's
quite common but to action it I action
it I'm like I will 100% regret not
having a crack at this you know like the
102 when I failed the first time there
was sort of talk about yeah well you
know James Lawrence is pretty impressive
guy like maybe you don't have it in you
buddy you know and I saw him on day 100
and yeah I mean he was delirious like he
struggled man exactly you know so so who
are you well exactly you know I've never
done a man the event in my life I've
never done a triathlon in fact I've I've
done three I've done three one-day
events in my life I ran the London
Marathon for the scouts uh I did a tough
M and I did a 50k Ultra a couple years
ago it literally other than training of
course I'm doing one day training and
things but actual events that's all I've
ever done I've never done any Triathlon
not once I've not done a a proper
running race it's just it one day events
have never excited me um so you're right
you know once when I failed last year it
was a huge part of me and people I know
and the internet going like who is this
guy likey right not so easy like come on
man like you know and um and of course
as I said like I plead guilty that by
the way well it was I Remember You Mess
when I when I announced the attempt I
remember you saying uh snap shots shots
fired shot Fir and and then at 6 and you
had that thing I was like maybe not as
no not like a sh and Freud way but out
of like a respect for just how how
difficult absolutely and yeah a huge
part of Me Maybe didn't take it
seriously enough there was that time
window where I sort of knew that 6
months wasn't enough but I thought I'm
just going to have a crack anyway
otherwise I'm waiting a whole another
year for the for this would have would
have been this year cuz the sensible
part of me would have been like when I
thought of it in January I would have
started in April the following year
which is what I said this year but of
course I'm like I don't want to wait 14
months I I want it now and I think I can
get there and I was wrong I was I was
wrong you know
I the route wasn't good enough I was a
little bit down on Fitness although even
day seven with the injury my all my
times were a little quicker so my swim
was quicker I think i' had done the
fastest bike on that day um my run was
slow super slow so I was sort of on the
right
track but yeah I I wouldn't have made it
because I just didn't I I I just winged
it a little bit too much this time um
and I I don't regret it because it
became fuel for my fire the next time
it's was like right well I've I cocked
that up what did I do wrong I'm going to
do it better uh I'm going to train a bit
more I'm going to work on a bit on my my
um my speed because I can go forever but
with doing the full a day to get the
sleep you got to be fast as well so I
had to bring in some speed work into my
training so I did that
worked on a better route um got you know
the crew got a different crew uh so yeah
everything I just did a bit better that
I'd messed up the time before MH um
because let's say I even had got to a
physical level I potentially would have
still messed up because of other things
had I not done the seven right and
actually so going back to getting to the
start line fully fit there's three
things I would do differently if I did
it again one is I would still do my
three sessions of each thing a week for
six to eight months I think that's how
long I did it eight months then I would
do a
weeklong uh bike packing ride about two
months out morning till night 200 miles
a day just cycle find out anything
that's weak you know because you'll pick
up all the the little weaknesses and
tendons and muscles by going day after
day on the bike I then would have taken
a week off and done the same on the run
and done a weekl long run with a
backpack fast packing a bit like what
I've got here to to run uh but I'd have
thrown a tent in there as well done that
for a week seeing what niggles I picked
up cuz that would have picked up my Weak
Knee for example and maybe my weak weak
right ankle and maybe this hip thing
I've got now uh and then I would have
done five in a row and I would have done
a five in a row about six weeks out and
that's controversial because and and the
reason I didn't is because I thought
well what if I get injured then it's
ruining my attempt but then if I get
injured doing five I'm getting injured
doing 105 right right you're just you're
just yeah you're basically uh you know
creating a situation where you can pull
out before you begin because you're
you're just realizing what's inevitable
yeah so let's say I did the five and I'd
picked up this knee thing I'd have gone
right why did that happen I need to work
on that go work with my physio work with
everyone so that it doesn't happen on
the 105 and so there's a couple of
things that happened not to say that the
love was going to go easy I love that
your training block is like okay I'm
just going to do these 200 mile days on
the and I'm G to do this insane run camp
and then I'm going to do five Iron Man's
in five days just just in training to
get ready I think you'd have to if you
just your like just the insanity of that
like in terms of how we think about
difficulty and what's possible versus
impossible like now having done 105 your
sense of normal is like so out of whack
compared to like the average person yeah
that you're like yeah then you do five
and then you do you know like like so
cavalierly so
casually yeah I don't know it does seem
normal if I'm honest like I I I'm trying
to right now think of someone else
looking at this and I I feels normal
right and that's what I want to I want
to we got to end this but I want to
bring that back to the person who's
watching or listening who who perhaps is
losing the thread right now because
they're just they can't relate um so
let's get back to ordinary
Jo I don't want to be normal yeah it's
like you're like the average ordinary
guy who also did this C crazy thing like
what is what exactly is average ordinary
or or normal about this nothing right
nothing no I like that um but to ground
it in in accessible principles as you
know the person who's going to write
this book with the 10 tools of endurance
what do you say to that person who is
struggling with committing to the hard
thing or trying to access a new gear
where they put themselves in a position
to struggle and fail and challenge
themselves physically mentally and
emotionally yeah I don't know if I'm
that sympathetic to people with little
self sort of motivation
so you know I I really struggle when I
meet people and they go like oh I just I
just didn't want to train to I'm
training for a marathon but I just
couldn't you I didn't train this week I
just couldn't be
honest I really don't like I just you
know I'm I'm not the The goggin Who
shout to you and gives you all that
motivation like if you don't want to be
motivated man like I just come on I I I
sort of I don't understand it I guess
cuz I'm so selfmotivated well also if
you're Reliant upon somebody else to
provide extrinsic motivation then that's
problematic because you got to find a
way to you got to keep getting that yeah
you have to be able to instill that in
yourself no but like so practically is
is find out why you want to do it you
know if you want to run a marathon or if
you want to do an Iron Man let's say you
want to do an Iron Man you've never done
an Iron Man why are you why are you
wanting to do it you know and and yeah
but you can't even answer that question
for yourself yeah well I want to chase
thing I no so genuinely I have zero
interest of doing an Iron Man a stand
alone event zero although James is uh he
wants to do a head-to-head on
his what he's ask he's like come be a
Day of
Reckoning more shots fired right um that
could be a pay-per-view his fastest is
10 hours he's done a 10 hour I think I
could do a 10 I think I could do a 10
what's your fastest Iron Man I've never
done an Iron Man have you
never you've done all the long stuff as
well so you get me yeah I understand I
understand but if let's say you wanted
to do one you've really got to a want it
and and if you don't want it don't do it
I think you should do it but I'm not
going to be there sort of setting your
alarm for for you and waking up in the
morning like but if You' decided you
want to do it like really focus and put
energy into the reasons why you're doing
it and write them out you know write
them on a poster not stick them next to
your bed if you're a visual type of
person or print pictures out I remember
when I swam the length of Britain I had
a picture of the Jonah gr's Harbor and I
printed it out and I had that as my
visualiz like that's where I want to get
to nothing else matters I got to swim to
that spot and um and you know write them
out why are you doing it is it to raise
money for charity is it for ego is it
for a cool Pub story um everything's
just as important as as as the other one
and try not to forget it and if you you
know and take the baby steps and Trust
the process and get other get advice
from people if if things if you're
getting injured especially with injury
that's a hard one of course because
there are certain times where injury is
you know will stop you and should stop
you because depending on what you want
to do after that it's being able to
differentiate good pain from bad pain
yes you know there's pain that's just
pain and you just deal with it and then
there's pain that will potentially lead
to something that will a have a lifelong
effect on you or be eventually stop you
later down the line and it's about
managing that um but for the most part
from a mindset point of
you yeah you just got to think why and
what's driving you what's your
motivating fact
and for me it's a record and it's trying
to do a thing at a certain time you know
I'm doing 100K Ultra uh at the end of
September I know I will never win that
race like it's just never going to
happen um it's I've not trained for it
uh I've not done Hills in months MH uh
however I really want to see just what I
can do how fast I can do it so I'm going
to push myself I'm going to look at my
numberers num which I normally don't do
and and just see so that's I'm chasing
this this philosophy of how well I can
do once I've set that time then and
let's say that time's close to the
winner of that particular race then
maybe the ter will be like oh maybe you
can win it next year you know I've
signed up for the 215 mile run across
Scotland for next
August now that's something I think the
the last year's winner was 58 hours and
I'm sort of going well I wonder if I
could do 58 hours as well so that's
something that's MH excites me and
that's all I need that I don't need any
other external motivation other than a
for this this 100 coming up is how how
quick can I do that uh and then and then
that's all I need I literally need
nothing else I'm so motivated do that I
don't care about any of that let me tell
you what I want to see from you okay I
want to see you and James go
head-to-head in a Mr Beast type video
challenge where you know you each have
to do something head to-head that
challenges you in a way that has nothing
to do with swimming biking and running
so yes James famously won that
competition where he wrote around on the
ferris wheel for however many days when
he was a kid right that's like his in
the superhero origin story of James's
life that would be the opening scene
right he refuse he rides it I don't know
how many days or whatever and refuses to
get off
on the kind of mental capacity uh level
Beyond normal people so in the way that
Mr Beast makes videos like whoever can
have their hand on the side of his boat
the longest wins the boat or whatever
like I I want to see you guys go head
tohe head in something like that um I'd
be a I think that would be great that'
be great yeah if anyone has fig that out
yeah yeah let's keep inou I mean like
just some ridiculous challenge that
really is more about your mind I think
than anything else that would excite me
that would excite me actually yeah yeah
we figure that out I want to do I'd like
to find interesting ways to push myself
that don't take for three and a half
months MH so and I think I'll need to
just to not be away from the family and
that's why I'm signing up for a little
bit more one-day races which I've never
done before um but maybe that's part of
it maybe there's these psychological
challenges that uh I could uh sort of
kind of scratch the terrier you know
yeah maybe that would also scratch but
maybe instead of scratching the terrier
Let's uh let's uh you know pet him a
little bit try to understand him you
know lock eyes with him see if we can
get a little communion here a little
deeper insight into why the terrier is
the way the terrier is you are right I'm
so terrified that he then decides to
there's nothing to be afraid
of uh self-awareness is power my friend
no it's true it's true and and and every
time I listen to One your podcast I sort
of go right I definitely need to work on
that side of me a little bit more maybe
my step into yoga is going to be a start
of it now I'm doing the breathing thing
which I poo pooed for ages and and um
but it's it's really revolutionized this
last so I've only done it this last week
I get up at 529 I do half an ey yoga and
it's the most transformative I've felt
out of all the other things like the ice
bath the saor uh you know diet changes
and that thing the simple thing I feel
has changed me the most I sleep better
for it um I feel better in the day um
yeah Caroline was like wow you you're in
such a good mood lately um so I'm
definitely going to but I'm doing the
classic sort of boy thing of like right
I want to get into yoga right is there a
three-hour yoga session I can do on
YouTube more is better more is better I
know it's Terri which is such a it's
antithetical to the Whole Yoga thing to
begin with right like it's hilarious and
I'm so terrible I'm shaking on every
pose and and I love being terrible
competitive in your Asos yeah um well
let's also work on maybe getting a few
vegetables in you as well oh so we I I
at home we I'm sort of part-time
vegetarian part-time vegan as well um
don't have a lot of meat in you're
growing some of your food and foraging
the mushrooms foraging I've got big
veggie plot as well uh the growing
season a bit bit rubbish so you get all
your vegetables in like a month one
month window type thing um but yeah
Caroline and I we will have a Sunday
roast on Sundays but mostly our weekday
meals are are pretty much vegetarian and
I really would like you know reading
reading your book really every I've read
it twice now and I'm like damn it I
really need to do this I really I really
need to just go go all in um but yeah
it's on my list it's you versus uh James
Lawrence who can sustain a vegan diet
the longest oh I think I could I no I
love it I actually you probably would
win that jam has tried we talked about
it I think it's habit it's habit more
than anything I think if so we do this
where they deliver all your the
ingredients to a meal every week in a
box and so that's all um I don't think
they do a vegan option but it's a
vegetarian option so we have four meals
a week at home that are mostly
vegetarian um and and I love it I I and
I feel better for it uh I also do feel
better with with game meat than so I do
try and only when I have meat it's
either official game um but yeah but on
on on the
105 yeah it just it's just I started
stomaching you maximize caloric density
basically and and also I wasn't there to
try and do a a sub you know sub 10 I
knew I needed the calories and I knew I
needed to survive the day and I needed I
needed to not lose weight um but food
very rarely changed my my energy levels
on on the one of cuz I was so fatigued I
was so tired I was in so much
pain if I ate nothing or everything I
was I still felt the same um so all it
was was just minimizing eventually going
off the cliff from a Performance Point
out cuz eventually at some point I'll
just waste away and have no power left
and then I'll be doing a 7-hour bike and
a 7h hour marathon and then I'm back on
the wave so and once I had a system
because I I ate almost the exact same
thing every day to the and at the same
time so I'd wake up out of porridge and
chia in the morning with butter and
honey and I'd have that very liquidy in
a liter and have that on the way to the
pool then I'd have a banana and then I'd
have some athletic greens and a couple
of multiv vits mhm then on the bike I'd
have small cheeses and small bits of
meat um then at the if I hadn't finished
the porridge by the pool I'd have that
before I got on the bike and then there
was three feed stations I'd have a
banana a packet of crisps um every now
and then there was some tomatoes and and
cucumber just to because I just fancy
them um I'd have something like a Welsh
cake I have a used what is a Welsh cake
oh youve not had a Welsh I should have
brought you some it's just like an a
flowy like cake with some raisins in it
yeah but no it's more crumbly um like a
scone if you flattened a scone scone
scone um it's sort of like that and then
I have the cream and then have uh some
nuts and some fruit lots of fruit right
um and I'd have that on each feed
station and then during the Run oh and
I'd also have uh rice pudding I don't
know if you get that but rice pudding
I'd have one of those at every feed
station then on the Run
bananas and um I'd have a pasta meal two
pasta meals on the Run uh full meal so
walking and eating with a spoon a carbon
or spag ball and then in my bottles I
had carb powders um in the bottle so I'd
have about 2,000 calories a day just in
the bottles maybe 3,000 in powder form
and then yeah that especially with the
cream because I'd have two 2,000 a day
in cream which for me was I'd eat eat
eat and then literally at the end i'
just down a bit of cream and then go and
then that was sort of insurance right
like if I messed up all the eating at
least I had that as backup right and
then that that kep me as I said I only
lost 3 kgs over the three months I was
happy with that I was happy with that
cuz people I could have lost 10 kgs I
could have gone down I'm only 5 foot I'm
under 5 fo8
so I could have been I could have gone
on to 60 kgs easily yeah from 70 so I
was happy with 67 I think what you've
done done is extraordinary uh it's a
testament to the human Spirit your
tenacity as this terrier and um just
inspirational for everybody to know that
you've had your blood work done you've
been in the lab and you've been tested
and there isn't anything physically
extraordinary about you beyond your
sheer determination your force of will
your refusal to give up your ability to
persevere against obstacles and this
proclivity to act I think is really
powerful and I think for anybody who's
listening or watching who is considering
um the upper ceiling of their
capabilities My Hope Is that maybe your
testimony will encourage people to
rethink that um because I think um it's
easy like I was saying before when you
start you know this new normal around
like oh 105 Iron Man's in 105 days like
whatever like oh we could maybe it's 200
like let's just do a reality check here
and
appreciate the extraordinary nature of
what you accomplished whether it was 100
101 102
105 this is a feat that I think very few
people can appreciate just how
extraordinary and difficult it is and as
I said to James and have said publicly
you know I think it's deserving of much
more attention from from the broader
kind of you know mainstream media than
either of you two guys have have
received uh I think you're deserving of
of much more attention and appreciation
for what you have accomplished because
it it it really is something that as
somebody who's dipped their toe in this
world I have a hard time understanding
or or or even having a taste for what
that must have been like yeah thanks
thanks for saying that I um yeah I
haven't really thought thought about the
external ramifications of where this has
gone and where it could go and who's you
know benefited from it and who's
inspired by it because I'm still only
four four and a half weeks out from it
so I think it'll take six months to a
year for me to probably decompress and
work out what actually happened yeah I
have no memory of Cu every day is the
same like when I C around the world
every day was different but this one
every day is the same so it all sort of
went into one big blur your relationship
with time shifts and you didn't know
what was going on in the world or
abely which is strange yeah it'll be a
while before it uh sinks in and becomes
I think once I've written the book and I
sit down and I it'll force you to
confront it yeah this happened and you
know you don't have to run to carfest if
you don't want to I think you earned a
little break I want to okay good um well
I'll see you there then I guess right
yeah absolutely cool um thank you for
coming here and sharing uh you are an
inspiration um amazing what you've done
and I can't wait to see what you've done
next not that you need to top it I'm
more interested in in how you synthesize
these experiences into actionable wisdom
for the rest of us through the book
you're going to write yeah thank you
very much yeah very very kind yeah so um
if people are Keen to learn more about
you they can go to Sean Conway Adventure
Sean conway.com or Sean Conway Adventure
inst Instagram few places yeah that's it
cool man all right thank you
cheers that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change and
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. ral.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davey Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt traper Patt
and Harry mathys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace
plance
[Music]
namaste
he